COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE RIVAS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS NINE FIVE ONE. SIX
THREE EIGHT NINE AGAIN TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SIX IS NINE FIVE ONE.
SIX THREE EIGHT NINE THOSE
AGAIN DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED. AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT SOMETIMES THERE
MAY BE A LAG SO IF YOU'RE
WATCHING ON THE- COMPUTER THERE
MAY BE A LAG FROM WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING ON THE PHONE. NOW I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR AFTER
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. EACH BILL WILL BE
INTRODUCED BY ITS AUTHOR ORDER
DESIGNEES E. WE WILL THEN HEAR
TESTIMONY FROM ONE OR TWO
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
DESIGNATED BY THE AUTHOR FOR UP
TO FOUR MINUTES. AFTER THIS
TESTIMONY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL ASK ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. TO SIMPLY IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES BY. DIGITIZATION AND
POSITION WILL THEN HEAR
TESTIMONY FROM ONE OR TWO
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL FOR UP TO
FOUR MINUTES AFTER OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'LL ASK ANY ADDITIONAL
COMPONENTS TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES BY NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. AGAIN EACH SIDE
WILL BE GRANTED A MAXIMUM OF
FOUR MINUTES FOR PRESENTATION.
WELL WE IN AND HEAR FROM
EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO THE
CLEAR TO POSITION ON EACH BILL
TO ENSURE THAT ALL THE BILL'S
INTERGENDER HEARD. HI IS THE
CHAIR MAKE CAP THE TOTAL TIME
FOR VERBAL TESTIMONY ON A BILL
GIVING HEARING TIME CONSTRAINTS.
COMMENTS ABOUT BILLS HERE TODAY
CAN BE SENT TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE STAFF AT A WEBSITE TO
ENSURE THAT ONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. TODAY
WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA. TO BILLS ARE ON CONSENT
THOSE ARE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWO TWO SIX FIVE BY SIMILAR
RECORDS SILVA. AND ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWO NINE THREE BY
SOMEONE OR MAYES. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT CENTER GROVE WILL NOT
BE IN ATTENDANCEAT TODAY'S
COMMITTEE HEARING. IN ADDITION
A SUMMER CAR I WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. FOR ITEM NUMBER
ONE AND THEY'LL BE HEARD AFTER
HIS UP ITEM. JUST ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL-
LET'S SEE. DO WE HAVE A QUORUM
ONE. TWO THREE FOUR. EIGHTY
FIVE YEAR OLD MONEY STEP DOWN
ONE TWO. OKAY SO BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION THE BILL'S LET US
FIRST ESTABLISH A QUORUM
ACTUALLY MONEY TO STEP OUT OF
THE AREA ALL RIGHT- CONSULTANT.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL NUMBER
GONNA ASK MEMBERS TO PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE TO
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE SO WE CAN
GET AN ACCURATE QUORUM CALL.
THESE CALL THE ROLL. CAN CAN
HEAR GONZALEZ. GROF FURTADO
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE MELENDEZ
HERE MELINDA'S HERE MITCHELL
MITCHELL HERE MITCHELL HERE
MINING. MINING HERE RUBIO
PRESENT RUBIO HERE. THANK YOU-
CONSOLE NOTES THAT A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND BEGIN OUR
AGENDA TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THE FILE
UNDER ONE WILL BE PRESENTED
AFTER- A NUMBER FOUR AND WE
PRESENT BY SUMMER CAR SO WE'RE
GONNA BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER. TWO AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
AUTHORED BY SENATORS CALDERON
AND SALAS SIMPLY BE A SELLER
CALDERON HERE 2% WELCOME. THANK
YOU SENATORS- AND MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF FOR ALLOWING THIS
MEASURE TO BE HEARD AND IT
TURNED TODAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT- AS IT AS AN AVID
SURFER I KNOW FIRST HAND THE
DIFFICULTY IN EXCESS- THE BEAT
AND THE COAST THIS IS. ACTUALLY
DIFFICULT FOR LIVE IN INLAND
COMMUNITIES DESPITE
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL LACKS-
GUARANTEED ACCESS FOR ALL
ACCORDING TO UCLA'S CALLS ACT
ALSO REPORT ROUGHLY 62% OF AN
INDIVIDUAL CITED PARKING
AFFORDABILITY OVERNIGHT
ACCOMMODATIONS AND LIMITED
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
VISITING PIMCO'S. 39% CENTRAL
VALLEY RESIDENT STATE THEY HAVE
VISITED LESS THAN ONCE A YEAR
OR ARE LESS LIKELY TO VISIT THE
COAST AT ALL. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO WANT TO LEARN HOW TO SERVE
FACE BUT A FACE BARRIERS IN
ACCESS. THE B. THERE IS A
SALUTE TO OPEN LEARN IN A SAFE
AND- PLACE THE WORLD'S GREATEST
SIR WE- REALLY NEAR HAVE
BROUGHT. THEIR ARTIFICIAL WAVE
TECHNOLOGY TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THE FOR OF A VENUE
THIS NOT PROVIDES TRIP TRANSFER.
TO ALL PROVIDE. S. PERFECT IN
THIS AREA. ARTIFICE WAVE YLIDES
ALLOW FAMILIES AND LEARN HOW
TO. AND HAVE. IN THE WATER
INSIDE THESE FOR ARE SPECIALLY
HELLO AND IT. SUFFERS FROM A
LOT OF SPACE. HEALTH RELATED
BENEFITS. EMERGE AS A WAY
PLEASE ENTERING THE GOLDEN
STATE. RELATIVE REYES. YEAH
UNIQUE TO THIS VENUE AS RICK.
TO ENSURE HIGH LEVELS OF SAFE
HEALTH AND- YET ALLOWING CIGNA
OPERATION FLEX. APPLICABLE FOR
ALL SHAPES AND SIZES. OF
ARTIFICIAL WAY FACILITIES
CURRENTLY ARTIFICIAL- WAY
FACILITIES CANNOT BE COMPARED
WITH THE PUBLIC. SWIMMING POOLS
OR WAY FORCED US MAKING POLLS
REGULATED OPERATION NOT OPERATE
NOW PROPRIA. FOR ARTIFICIAL WAY
FACILITIES WERE FULL AND WAVE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION HAVE
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS. FROM
THE CONSTRUCT AND OPERATION OF
ARTIFICIALLY SEVENTY. THIS BILL
SAYS FOR. SPECIFIC REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND OVERSIGHT TO
ENSURE PERMITTING AND OVERSIGHT
FALLS UNDER THE LOCAL AGENCIES
IN WHICH STARTED WAIT TILL IT
IS LOCATED WE HAVE WHAT.
SEVENTY HELLO. AND
PROFESSIONALS ARE COMPLETE.
WERE HELD AT STATE. THEY CREATE
AN ECONOMIC HUB OF A- IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY CITY. WHILE
THERE IS ONLY ONE ARTIFICIALLY
FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA MANY
OTHER FACILITIES ARE IN THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE PERMITTING
PROCESS THIS BILL ENSURES THESE
ARTIFICIAL WAY FACILITIES ARE
REGULATED APPROPRIATELY BUT
ALSO ALLOW BEACH ACCESS TO THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND I WOULD
JUST SAY. SOME IS A PART OF
THIS COMMUNITY I GREW UP IN
THIS COMMUNITY SERVING AS BEEN
A HUGE PART OF MY LIFE GROWING
UP THESE FACILITIES ARE GOING
TO BE A MAINSTAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND YOU'RE GONNA SEE A LOT OF
THESE FACILITIES COMING TO. OUR
STATE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE A UNIFORM SET OF POLICIES
AND REGULATIONS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PERMITTING OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND OPERATION AT THESE
FACILITIES AND THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- IT'S A HUGE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS FOR THE CITIES IN THE
UNITIES. THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
IN A LOT OF WORK HAS GONE INTO
F. COUNTIES. AND PART OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. SURE WE GOT IT
RIGHT. I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
GOTTEN IT RIGHT IN THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT POLICY MOVING
FORWARD. AS THESE FACILITIES
ARE BEING DEVELOPED BECAUSE
THEY ARE HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
IN IS AN IMPORTANT TIMELY
DISCUSSION HAVE. REGARDING THE
OPERATION. USED IN OPERATION OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR. THESE
ARTIFICIALLY FACILITY SO THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE. AND HERE TO TESTIFY ON
THE PHONE- IN SUPPORT. THIS
JOHN LUFF WHO IS THE FOUNDER OF
SURF PARK CENTRAL AND CHAIR OF
THE COUNCIL. FOR THE MODEL
AQUATIC HEALTH CODE
SPECIFICALLY THE AD HOC CIRCLE
COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS JUSTIN
MILAN WHO IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF CENTER
CALDERON FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE INTO
TESTIMONY FOR SUPPORT. THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
INSTITUTING A FOUR MINUTE. TIME
LIMIT ON TESTIMONY SO WITH TWO
WITNESSES YOU GOT TWO MINUTES
APIECE BUT TOTAL FOUR MINUTES.
AGAIN DECIDED TO PERMIT AN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME. IS
DETERMINED AND- ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. SO WELL LET'S GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH THE TWO
IDENTIFIED- SUPPORT WITNESSES-
WE HAVE- OF. JOHN LUFF AND-
ALSO- GILLIAN MALONE I
UNDERSTAND IT AND OF MR LEFT IS
ON THE PHONE I HAD BLESSED HER
OKAY HE DIED TURKEY MIGHT NOT
BEEN YET SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH THEM MR LOS. YEAH
I'M JOHN LUCK PRESIDENT OF
THEIR PARTY CENTRAL WELL TO THE
COMPANY BEHIND THERE ARE NONE
THAT WHICH HE CO PRODUCED
ALONGSIDE AND YOU GET THE
UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR THIRTY
THREE THIRDS. I'M ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL FOR THE
MODELS BY L. THEN YOU ADD HOC.
COMMITTEE ON HIS FORM LAST YEAR.
HE WAS BORN OUT AND MORE CLEAR
THEN USE BEING. IN PROPERTY
VENUE THAT UNIQUE THAT. AND
OPERATIONAL REQUIREMENTS WHICH
THE CURRENT MODEL QUALITY
HEALTHCARE DID NOT ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS AND THEREFORE NEED
UPDATED. THE THIRD AT HOW MANY
MEMBERS INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE EDT I CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER
SPECIALIZING IN AQUATIC. IT'S
ACTED THE PART OF THE HEALTH
OFFICIAL THAT HAD UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES DEALING WITH BURKE
THE NEW PUBLIC THEIR VENUES IN
THE UNITED STATES. AND MANY OF
THE WORLD'S TOP WEIGHT MAKING
COMPANIES SEVERAL WHICH YOUR
DATE HERE. IN CALIFORNIA. A
MANY OF YOU ARE LIKELY AWARE.
THIRTEEN IT'S NOT A TO CAL.
DAHLE ORG EIGHT OR- MANY WOMEN
IN ISRAEL GROWING. AND CAL BAN
BECOME THE MANDATE THAT THE
NATION'S CAPITAL OF THE WORLD.
VENUES AND MANDATE THAT THE
NATION ARE POWERFUL ECONOMIC
CATALYST. THEY'RE DRIVING
TOURISM ALREADY GENERATING
REGIONAL NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL THEIR
VENUE THAN IT DOES TODAY.
TRANSLATE TO SIGNIFICANT
DRIVERS TAX REVENUES FOR THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY BURKE
AND YOU ARE LOCATED. WITH
CERVANTES ALSO COMPANY IT CAN
LEVEL THE JOB CREATION AND
DEPENDING ON THE SIDE IN THE
THIRD VENUE ON THE THURSDAY AND
THEN THEY COME WITH- HOTELSAND
RESORTS RESTAURANTS RETAIL BUT
THEN THEN YOU THE MORE.
ANYWHERE FROM DOZENS TO
HUNDREDS OF JOBS ARE CREATED AT
EACH LOCATION. CALIFORNIANS
ALREADY HOME TO MORE WEIGHT
COMPANIES THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD. A COMPANY NOW OWNED
BY THE WORLD SURF LEAGUE WHICH
IS HEADQUARTERED IN SANTA
MONICA. THEY ARE ALSO THE UNDER
THE THIRD BRANCH WHICH IS
LOCATED IN THE MORE CALIFORNIA
ON THE ONE OF THE BEST MANDATE
BURKE THEN USE ON THE PLANET.
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF THE STATE
AMERICAN WAVE MACHINES AND
STANDING OF A THIRD BLOCK WHICH
IS THE WAY THE COMPANY BEHIND
THE NEW CALL BRING. TERMINALS
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
CALIFORNIA HAS LOOK. KNOWN THE
WORLD GREATEST MAN THERE THAT
NEEDS AND THIRD THEN YOU. AND
BILL IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PART. OF MAKING THAT HAPPEN.
AND BY PROVIDING A UNIFORM
POLICY STATE WIDE. KELLY
THROUGHOUT THE DAY WHAT IT
CLEARS THAT RECOMMENDATION TO
FOLLOW AND WORKING WITH BOTH
THECURRENTAND FUTURE SIR THEN
YOU THROUGHOUT THE- DAY. THIS
ONE SURE THAT THERE'S A CLEAR
PATH. ONE WHICH WE LACK TODAYWELL THEY COLDER THAN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND SAFE OPERATION
CERVANTES. PROUD CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH THERE'S ABOUT THE LITTLE
AND A MINUTE A HALF LEFT- NEXT
IS MISTER MILAN. THANK GOODNESS
TEACHERMEMBERS- JOKING LEARN
TO THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS AND WE- ARE THE FOLKS
THAT PROVIDE THE PERMITTING AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE- PUBLIC POOLS.
FANTASY AUTHOR MENTIONS THESE
AREN'T EXACTLY LIKE THE REGULAR
PUBLIC SCHOOL. SO WE DO WANT TO
THANK. ALL THOSE INVOLVED IN
THIS BILL IS BASICALLY THE OLD
PENNY STOCKS. INDEX JERRY TOO
MANY PEOPLE WORKING WITH US TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS SOME
OF THE UNIQUE. HEALTH SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. ARE WE PLEASED TO
BE ABLE TO OFFER OUR SUPPORT.
WE ARE PLEASED THAT YOU TOOK
THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKE A
MAN INTO CAR FIRE. THAT THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS OF THE ONE
TO PROVIDE THE. ANOTHER SITE.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SHOULD
BE REGULATORY AUTHORITY IN CASE
YOU NEED TO TREAT THE AS WE
MOVE SO THANKS FOR EVERYBODY'S
BY THIS ON FOLDER ONE OF WAY IT
CAN. THANKS FOR MUCH FOR THIS
PRESENT NOW WE'LL- ACCEPT THAT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
POSITION. SAYS ORGANIZATION
POSITION FOR STARTING THE
GALLERY. SAYING NO ONE ATTHE
GALLERY WHO WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM LET'S REMOVE THE ROOM
IS AT ONE TWELVE. ALRIGHT IS
ANYONE SPEAKING. AND STANDING
AT THE MICROPHONE AT ONE TWELVE
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES AND CALL THE SUPPORT WHEN
THIS IS. VISUALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AT NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE MY EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE EIGHTY
TWO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AMONG. LET'S TRY
ONE MORE TIME AND THEN LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE. NINE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND MOVING ON AT NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR. NINE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD CLICK. YEAH THAT'S
WHAT IT. DON'T WANT ANYONE TO
BE ABLE TO. AND LINE FIFTY SIX.
DOES YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SHEILA
HERNANDEZ FROM THE TRANSIT IN A
COLLISION I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO
EIGHT TANK OF THE CHANGES ARE
HONEST I'M DISABILITY FIND OOPS
SORRY THIS IS A YOU NEED TO
WAIT FOR THAT BILL WE ARE
HEARING AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE. SO
THAT'LL BE COMING UP LATER
SORRY. CAN WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT WITNESS AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN FAVOR OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
BY SEVEN MEMBERS CALDERON AND
SALAS. AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND MINE. YES PLEASE NINE ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M HERE MY NAME IS
MARIE AND I'M CALLING PROJECT
TRACKER YOU KNOW COALITION I AM
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF IT AB
TWENTY EIGHT. I'M SORRY AND
IT'S HARD TO FIND SORRY WE WILL
BE HEARING THAT BILL LATER ON
TODAY THIS IS WE ARE CURRENTLY
HEARING EIGHTY ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
SO. IF YOU ARE WAITINGTO FIND
ANOTHER BILL PLEASE HANG ON THE.
LINE RIGHT NOW WE'RE HEARING.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE. ARE THERE
ANY WHETHER WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO SPEAK ON ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
AND SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THERE ARE NO IDENTIFIED
WITNESSES FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE- FIRST WHEN I
GO TO THE GALLERY OR TO ANY
WITNESS WHO WHICH TESTIFIED. IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE. SAY NONE AT THE
MICROPHONE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
OF LESS ONE TWELVE. C. NOLAN-
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
TEST FOUND THIS BILL LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE.
MODERATOR PLEASE. OPEN THE
LINES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH SAID
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE ON RECREATIONAL WATER USE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT OKAY THANK YOU I WOULD
BE JUST AS A REMINDER FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING- THIS
HEARING ONLINE THERE IS
SOMETIMES A LAG. SO IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY PLEASE LISTEN OVER
THE PHONE TO BE SURE THAT YOU
CAN COMMENT TIME IN A TIMELY
MANNER. SO WITH THAT LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ABOUT EIGHTY ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
SUMMER HER TAUGHT ME STATE
SENATOR TONYA SORRY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I'D LIKE TO
ASK IF I COULD. JUMP ON AND YOU
KNOW THE CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS- SAYING
NONE OTHER FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ACT I JUST WANNA SAY
SUMMER CALDERON I WANT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL- I
KNOW THAT- WELL- THIS BILL IS
ONE THAT YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD ON I KNOW THAT WE PH
R COMMITTEES AND WORKING WITH
YOU ON THAT THE THIS BILL I
KNOW I'M VERY HAPPY IT'S BEEN
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER. I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE AT LEAST FOR NOW AND IN YOUR
SERVICE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR- FOR FAMILY REASONS AND
PRESHEAF YOUR SERVICE AND I'M
GLAD WE'RE ABLE TO HEAR THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT YOU
HAD BEFORE- YOU ARE COMPLETING
THIS TERM AND WITH THAT- BUT
SOME OF THE BILL. OKAY THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SERETIDE-
IT'S UNDER WHICH I LIKE TO
CLOSE HIS WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK IN
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WALDRON
SO THE MEMBERS IN THIS BILL
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR OVER A
YEAR PRETTY OVER NINETEEN I
REALLY RESPECT THE WORK OF THE
SENATE AND ALWAYS COMING BACK
HERE IS CAN BE SOMETHING I'M
GONNA THIS BUT THEY YOU SO FOR
YOUR TIME AND- ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS. BILL I THANK VERY
MUCH TO SEND THEM. SO YOU CAN
AB ELEVENTH ONE AND MOVE BY
SENATOR TOM THE IS PASS TO
SECTOR PLEASE THE ROLL. HAN HI
CAN I GONZALEZ I. HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH FURTADO NINE FOR TITLE I
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE AT MELINDA'S
LINDA'S AYE ITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING NINE MONEY
I RUBIO I. RUBIO HI. EIGHT YOUR
BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK
RECLAMATIONS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT OUR NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB. TWENTY ONE
TWELVE BY SOME MEMBER RAMOS I
SEE YOU HERE OKAY WELCOME.
PLEASE COME UP TO THE PODIUM.
RIGHT NOW WLCOME YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- SENATORS- FOR ALLOW
ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY STATING THAT
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. DEEMED AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
EVEN BEFORE THE CURRENT CO IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SUICIDE RATES
AMONG ALL GROUPS HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY DRASTIC HAVE BEEN
INCREASING DRASTICALLY.
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE OF EX
AFFECT PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE BUT RISK OF SUICIDE IS
ESPECIALLY SIGNIFICANT AMONG
ADOLESCENTS OLDER ADULTS
VETERANS AND THE LGBTQ YOUTH
AND ADULTS. SUICIDE RISKS IS
ALSO VERY SIGNIFICANT IN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH FACE
HIGHER RATES OF SUICIDE THAN
THEIR PEERS IN ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS OF SUICIDE REQUIRE OF
FOCUS ON NATIVE AMERICAN YOU.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AT GREAT
RISK PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC IN
ARE AT EVEN GREATER RISK NOW
COBEN NINETEEN IS UNPRECEDENTED
AND WILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON TO THE COMMUNITIES
MENTAL HEALTH DUE TO ANXIETIES.
CAUSED BY MANY FACTORS SUCH AS
ISOLATION GRIEF. OVER LOST OF
FRIENDS DUE TO COLDER NINETEEN
IN SAMBAR DINO COUNTY OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE SOME CALM
AND ALLIES HAVE BEEN TAKEN BACK
OVER NINETY. WE SEE ALL THESE
ISSUES INCREASING AS WELL AS
THOSE THE STILL STRUGGLE WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE AND THE
WEIGHT OF THE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP.
WE NEED TO PREPARE NOW FOR
INCREASED PRESSURE ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM NOT
ONLY DURING THIS CRISIS BUT FOR
ITS AFTERMATH IN THE UPCOMING
YEARS. SO WE ARE PREPARED WITH
RESOURCES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES SO THAT WE HAVE
THEY SAW THAT THEY HAVE
SOMEWHERE TO TURN TO BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE. LIKE THE
SITUATION IN MY COLLEAGUES
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF SANGER.
THESE ISSUES ARE VERY MUCH REAL
AND THEY AFFECT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES EVEN NOW WE HAVE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
CALLS TO SUICIDE HOTLINES
ACROSS THE STATE AND CURRENT
COUNTY. THE CRISIS ON THESE
FRONTLINE SYSTEMS REFLECT THE
COMING CRISIS OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WE MUST BE PREPARED TO
MEET. WE MUST COME TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF SUICIDE
WE MUST TAKE DELIBERATE STEPS
TO STEM THE TIDE OF FALLOUT
FROM THE PANDEMIC. AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE TAKES THE FIRST STEP
IN ADDRESSING THE CURRENT
CRISIS OF SUICIDE BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS OFFICE WILL CENTRALISE
STATE RESOURCES MARSHALL
EXPERTISE AND BUILD ON THE
VITAL WORK OF STAKEHOLDERS LIKE
THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE WITHME TO
PRISONERS AND IF I CAN ASK BOTH
PRESENTERS TO STAY WITHIN THE
TWO MINUTES OLD BUT IT TO EAT
BAKER. STAY WITH ABOUT FOUR
MINUTES. ME TOO. EVEN SERVICE
AND DR VERGE MORE FROM THE TO
FOR NAY AMERICAN FAMILY
SERVICES MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANKS VERY MUCH- BEFORE WE
BEGIN CENTER RIVER DID YOU HAVE
OKAY ALL RIGHT- SO LET'S GO
AHEAD AND HERE FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND AS YOU
MENTIONED- WE HAVE EVA THRICE'S
AND DOCTOR VIRGIL MOOREHEAD YES
AND I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT. YOU
HAVE A TOTAL TOGETHER OF A FOUR
MINUTES I'LL SORT OF GIVE YOU
THE TWO MINUTE WARNING MEANS
THE FIRST WITNESS IT'S TWO
MINUTES SO THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE
EATING INTO THE OTHER PERSON'S
TIME SO IT THAT- LET'S GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH EVEN. THREATS
THIS. AFTER TEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF ABOUT THE
BENEFITS PLEASE PRESIDENT OF
THE POLICY HAD A PROFOUNDLY
SERVICES. ONE OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AND CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY. WE PROVIDE SERVICES AND
TWENTY EIGHT COUNTY
CONSIDERABLE OVERTHIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN AND FAMILY
ANNUALLY. WE ARE ALSO MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
THE CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
KOLPAN SERVING THERE. I'M
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE. A BILL WITH SIGNIFICANT
IMPORT PARTICULARLY IN THE
CURRENT TIME OF CALL THE
NINETEEN. AS WE ALL KNOW SB AND
THE NUMBER ONE ALLUDED TO GRIEF
LONELINESS ECONOMIC STRESS.
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE FUTURE
ALL PANDEMIC RELATE TO MOTIONS.
AND OFTEN FEELING OF
HOPELESSNESS. AND THANK HELLO
THE OFFICIAL DATA BE OF THE FOR
TIME WE DO MIL CALLS THE
HOTLINE. RIGHT FIRE OR HAVE
THIRDS WHICH IS A DISASTER
TREND KEVIN DE SHOWING THAT
GOES THE MOST COMMON METHOD OF
THE BED AND YOUR- THIS. RELATED
TO CALL NINETY AMPLIFY CREED
FIFTEEN AND MENTAL HEALTH. I
PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THE GAP WITH.
PARTICULARLY CAN YOU OF COLOR
AND WITH OUTCOME IN THE
DETERMINANTS THAT. ALSO
CONVENTION AND ARE YOU'RE
ACROSS THE STATE. WE CORD IN.
CLEAR MESSAGES ABOUT PRACTICE.
AND DIGITAL MONITOR OF BOTH AYE
DADDY IT ESPECIALLY FOR THE
WITH A HIGH WITH THE OF THAT.
YOU PARTICULARLY AMERICAN.
OLDER ADULTS AND LG HE
INDIVIDUALS. NO QUESTION THE
PRESIDENT OF TIME HAVING
TESTIFIED MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACED BY MANY
CALIFORNIANS. WE ASK THAT YOU
VOTE TODAY TO SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY ONE TWELVE THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS- VIRGIL
MOOREHEAD. HI AND BYE DOCTOR
VIRGIL MORTGAGE THEN YOU'RE A
PART OF THAT BIG LEGAL
RANCHERIA DUROC AND TAILLON
NATIVE AMERICAN AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TO BETTORS
NEIGHBOR BURKE AND FAMILY
SERVICES WERE UP IN THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY ANSWER SOME OF
THE MOST WILL MORE. OF RULE AND
ISOLATED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE INCLUDING ON THE HOPE OF
VALLEY RESERVATION IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE SERVED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED NATIVE
AMERICAN YOU AND ALSO- PROVIDED
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. TO SOME OF THE MOST.
I THEY'VE AMERICAN YOUTH
INCLUDING USE THAT. **** AT THE
APPLICATION OF A SHE WAS TRYING
TO THAT OCCURRED FIVE YEARS AGO.
ON THE EUROCLEAR. IT'S SO YOU
KNOW I. TO BETTER. NO SERVE IN
A LEADERSHIP ROLE BUT DO DIRECT
PRACTICES I SAW OVER FORTY TO
FIFTY. KIDS A WEEK AND
BEHAVIORAL INDIVIDUAL
PSYCHOTHERAPY AND GROUP THERAPY
SO I COULD TAKE FIRSTHAND I SEE
THE STRUGGLE- THE ONGOING
STRUGGLE THAT MANY OF OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH CONTINUE
TO FACE. AND I THINK THE TIME
IS NOW TO GET MORE SUPPORT OF
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL DEMAND
BECAUSE WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE
TO DECLARE ANOTHER. SUICIDE
EPIDEMIC IN OUR COMMUNITY YOU
KNOW THAT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
YOUTH THAT WE WORK QUICKLY TO
BATTERS ARE EAGER TO CHECK TO
GET SERVICES THEY REACH OUT BUT
WE NEED HELP AND WE NEED
SUPPORT- THE TIME IS NOW TO
RESPOND. I THINK NIMBLY AND
QUICKLY. SHE WAS DANGEROUS.
TRANSPIRED BECAUSE WITH THAT
THE COSBY MANY OF THE USERS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WHERE THERE
ARE ISOLATED LONELY AND REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH A LOT OF
ANXIETY AND SO THE MORE WE CAN
PRIORITIZE PREVENTION. THE MORE
WE CAN PRIORITIZE. INTERVENTION
BROWN. I WISH FACTORED THE MORE
WE ARE ON BOARD AT. THEY
REMEMBER AND BELLA SERVICES.
AND SO THEY YOU FOR SUPPORT OF.
A. TWO ONE ONE TWO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF YOUR TESTING. I
NOW WILL TAKE OTHER WITH IN
SUPPORT AND TO. ORG POSITION
WILL BEGIN THE GALA. I DO NOT
SEE ANY WITNESS WISHING TO FOR
THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
ONE ONE TWO. NOT SEE ANYONE
COMING UP TO TESTIFY ROOM- ONE
ONE TWO LET'S MOVE TO
TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR.
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
FOR SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO ONE ONE TWO
ON SUICIDE PREVENTION. THANK
YOU AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SAID PETE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE OR TWO ONE ONE TWO. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST LINE COMES
FROM RUNNING FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND- THANK
YOU NEXT WHAT'S IN MIND EIGHTY
EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AMANDA REVEALED THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS IN LINE FORTY
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TYLER IN THE
ACCOUNTING HEALTH THE VOCATION
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE THANK YOU. TO SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU KNOW HOW WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE TWENTY YOUR LIFE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON COOLEY SHOCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA COURT DATE THANK YOU X.
WITNESS. NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
TIME IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
MAC MILLAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
IN SUPPORT OF TWO ONE ONE TWO.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND I'M
HAPPY. CALIFORNIA IN PART THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE COULD BE
BALLOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS SHE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THE RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS TELLING
HIM THAT I WOULD AND WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT AND CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS.
NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON. HELLO ON BEHALF AND
QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
RIGHT AFTER THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY MANY HATE WHAT THE
I'M SORRY YOUR GO AHEAD MY NAME
THE NUMBER OF HATE WITH THE
DEATH OF THE DICTATOR HERE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES I.
REPORT OF A. TWO TWO. NEXT
WITNESS. ONE THIRTY FIVE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ADRIAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. FOR
CHILD FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE NO MORE
COMMENTED YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY JUST CHECK ONE MORE TIME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO ONE ONE TWO OR TWENTY ONE
TWELVE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
TONIGHT. NINE ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE NINE ONE THIRTY SIX
STRAPPED ONE MOMENT BURNETT
COMING. MY THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH CONTROVERSIAL THAT TRUE.
YEAH THE- THERE IS NO PROBLEM.
NINE THIRTY NINE. ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE.
HI THIS IS A DEATH FOR ALL ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES LGBT
CENTER AND WE ARE- SPEAKING OUT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE AS THE LEAD
OPPOSITION CAMILLE. GET WE ARE
ON THE CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO LIFE
SO CAME PLEASE BRING ONLINE.
HELLO THE HI. THIS WITH GOOGLE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES I'M
HERE. WE CAN YEAR YEAH- SENATOR
PETE. SENATOR CAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MOST OF THE MEMBERS. MY
IS AMIR GEN. ONE RIGHT SO I.
AND WE BEEN OPPOSITION THEY'LL
SEND WITH A THIRTY STARTED
BEGINNING. KERN WE'VE BEEN AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
VERY EAL PRINCE AND SHOCK
ABOUT THOSE WHO COMMITTEE
SUICIDE OR WHO FAIL IN THEIR
ATTEMPTS CONNECT SUICIDE WE
KNOW THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN
WHICH THINK THEY WANT TO BE
HELPFUL. DO NOT. BILL AB THREE.
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF THE WAY
IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE HELP THOSE
WHO WISH TO CONNECT SUICIDE AND
THOSE WHO ARE LESS AS MORNING
THE PEOPLE WHO AND. PHILISTINES.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR THIS BILL
IS PERHAPS CHAU PIECES WE USED
THAT YET HAS EMBRACED. AFTER A
BREAK RESEARCH ON IT OUT OF A
RESPONSE TO GOVERNOR SOME CALL
OR MAN FOR DOING SOMETHING
REGARDS THE RESILIENCE PROJECT.
WHICH APPEARS TO BE MORE FANCY
WAY OF SAYING LET LET THE LOWER
HER ON THE EAST EDGES IT WAS
DYING BY SECTION DROPPED THE
CURVE HELLO BIT IN THE BILL IT
IS REFERRED TO AS DRY. ZERO BUT
I DO REAL DRIVING FOR OWN THE
GENERAL OF. I TRANSIT. I ARE WE
LOOKING FOR PERFECTLY SO IT'S
TIME ARE WE LOOKING TO GET RID
OF SO IT'S- WHATEVER YOU WE ARE
LOOKING FOR A BIT BILL DOES NOT
DO IT. THIS ARE ANOTHER WAY TO
WE WANT TO READ THE BUDGET WITH.
HOLES AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE.
AND KNOWINGLY THAT SPOKE IN
FAVOR OF PRETTY MUCH SUPPORTED
WHAT I AVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS IS VERY GOOD THIS IS A
BILL THAT IS BEING SUPPORTED BY
DOZENS AND DOZENS ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICULARLY ONE TYPICAL OF A
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS. WORKING ON A THE
JEWISH SIDE A LONG TIME AND YOU
THE NUMBERS ON A CONSTITUENTS.
SALES OR COMPLETED. HAS RISEN
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE
CENTURY. YOUR WRITING A BILL
THAT COLLECT MORE DATA SAID
CREATE ANOTHER ADVISORY BOARD
WITH THE OVERALL OF NAMES. SO
CALLED IMPORTANT PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS
WAR SEPARATE OF ASSISTED
SUICIDE IS NOT GOING TO HELP
THE ONES WHOSE CHILDREN AND
WARDS HUSBANDS OR WIVES
CURRENTLY OR IN THE FUTURE WILL
COMMIT. SUICIDE CAN'T YOU. WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE. IS A
GREAT. YEAH ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WE FIND THAT THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO CHRISTIAN
REPRESENTATION WHATSOEVER. AND
THE FACT THAT THE DATE YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR PERMANENT ANSWERS
YOU'VE CHOSEN A PATH OF BEST
PRACTICES. WE TRIED VERY NAME
CHANGES DANGER GATE BECAUSE
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS BEST
PRACTICES ONLY WELL INTENTIONED
PRACTICES. SOME OF WHICH- AND
WHICH AREN'T WHICH TAKES ME
BACK TO THIS WE BELIEVE EIGHT
TWENTY ONE WHAT IS NOT. PATHWAY
TO SUCCESS IN GETTING TWO ZERO
AND. I SHOULD GET. N. AS LEADER
AND PLEASE NOT WASTE. THIS IS
THE TIME MONEY ENERGY OR YOU
TIME AND ENERGY. DO NOT PASSAGE
LOOK FOR SOME BETTER THANK YOU
YOUR YOUR YOU HAVE EXCEEDED
YOUR TIME THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TEST LOW MOVE TO PEOPLE
WISH TO TEST. IN A POSITION NAY.
N. .ORG IS A DOES ANIMALS FIRST
GO TO THE GALLERY. DO NOT SEE
ONE APPROACHING MIKE FROM THE
GALLERY MOVE TO ROOM- ONE
TWELVE. DO NOT SEEM AN
APPROACHING THE MY FRONT ROOM
ONE TWELVE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE. MODERATOR
THANK YOU MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES. TO
AB. TWENTY ONE TWELVE THANK.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE. S. ONE
AND THEN ZERO A FEW MOMENTS FOR
THE NINE NUMBERS. NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KILLING ME SO- SHUTTING
CALIFORNIA LIFE ON THE STREET.
AND I OPPOSE- TWENTY ONE
TWENTY. THANKS VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR PHONE MAYBE A NEW. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MAYOR SCOTT
PETERSON I AM ABSOLUTELY
AGAINST- TWENTY ONE TWELVE I'M
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR MY
WITHOUT QUESTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH-
LET'S BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- WELL FIRST OF ALL
AND I THINK THAT. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TOM THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- HEY WE
HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS PRIOR TO
HIM COMING TO OUR HOUSE. TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AND I'M
HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL I WANTED.
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
STATEMENT ON THE COLLAR IS MADE
THAT. IT WON'T HELP INMY
OPINION DOING NOTHING AT ALL IS
NOT AN OPTION. I ARE DISCUSSED
WITH THE AUTHOR ARE WERE BASED
ON A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT I
SEE OVER THE YEARS. AS AN
EDUCATOR A TEACHER FIRST AREAS.
WERE WELL AWARE THAT. THE SITE
WAS INCREASE AMONG OUR TEENS IN
OUR SCHOOL AND- BASED ON THE-
DIPLOMA PUBLIC. WHERE DID WAS
THE SECOND LEADING ATTEMPT
AMONG TEENS. AND YOUNG ADULTS
BETWEEN THE OF A AND TWENTY
FOUR HEARING AS A LOCAL. MEMBER
I ALSO HAD THE MISFORTUNE OF
GETTING ALL THE TEXT MESSAGES
AND INFORMATION WHEN HE- WOULD
FIND SOMEONE DISEASE BASED ON
YOU KNOW BY SUICIDE AND SO
THERE WERE MANY CASES. I THINK
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY CLOTHING
NINETEEN HAS REALLY. ISOLATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME AS IT WAS PRIOR
TO CLOTHING EIGHTEEN WE- WE
ALREADY WERE DEALING WITH AN
INCREASE IN SUICIDE WE ALREADY
DEALING WITH THE SITUATION. AND
THAT. IT'S NOT GONNA GET ANY
BETTER I ALREADY KNOW ALL
TEENAGERS TO OUR- THERE I.
DON'T HAVE A SUPPORT SYSTEM AND
PARENTS AND THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE- CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SLIPS
TOUCHES EVERY SINGLE PROFESSION
EVERY SINGLE E. FOR EVERY
SINGLE. COMMUNITY WE HEARD OF
TRIBAL ENTITY. I HAD A FRIEND
WHOSE HUSBAND. COMMITTED
SUICIDE FORMER VETERAN POLICE
OFFICER. A LOT OF WAYS A
COMMUNITY DON'T WASTE SOMETHING
ABSOLUTELY NO. IN MY OPINION.
AND IT DOESN'T. TO HAVE THEM
FOR OUT OF HIM. EXPE BEST
PRACTICES AND THERE IS BEST
PRACTICES IN MY OPINION ARE
THAT WE CAN DRAW UPON. THAT'S I
STAY SO I AGAIN. PROUD TO BE
CLOTH AND I. AM OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
WELL I AM HAPPY TO HEAR THAT SO
MANY MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
OUR KNOWLEDGE AND ALL OF THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THE STATE
BEING SHUT DOWN- INTERPRETER TO
THE CABIN NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND I HOPE THAT THAT MEANS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES WILL JOIN ME IN
MY EFFORTS. TO END A STATE OF
EMERGENCY- AND THEN THE SHIP
DOWN WITH THE C. R. NINETY
THREE THAT BEING SAID- I DO
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. SO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FOURTEEN OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN DIRECTED THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP A NEW STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO YEARS. THEY
DEVELOP THIS PLAN BASED ON THE
LATEST RESEARCH ON SUICIDE AND
ITS PREVENTION- AND WITH INPUT
AND GUIDANCE- EXCUSE ME WITH
INPUT AND GUIDANCE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE A FIVE
YEAR STRATEGIC PLAN AS WELL SO
I AM. TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS NEW. OFFICE IS GOING TO DO
MORE THAN WHAT THE ORIGINAL ONE.
DID IT JUST IT SEEMS
DUPLICATIVE I I'M I'M WITH YOU
ON DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN- TO
PREVENT SUICIDE ABSOLUTELY I'M
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IT
JUST IT SEEMS TO POCKET EVAN
AND I COULD BE READING IT
INCORRECTLY WOULD YOU. CARE TO
COMMENT ON THAT ASSEMBLY
DAUGHTER FIND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU A
SENATOR MELENDEZ AM CERTAINLY
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
THERE'S A STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
TOOK PLACE AND IT CAME OUT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS- DURING THAT
TIME AND ONE OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS TO CREATE
THIS OF THE OFFICE SUICIDE
PREVENTION. SO COMING OUT OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT NOT
IN FAILURE TO ACT ON THOSE IT
AS FAR AS CREATING THIS OFFICE
IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
SO MANY LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST IN
MY DISTRICT A SIXTH GRADER LOST
HER LIFE DURING THE TIME.
INDIAN RESERVATIONS 33%
INCREASE WITHIN THE INDIAN
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S TIME THAT WE
HAVE A STATEWIDE OFFICE OF THEN
WE CAN COLLECT THAT DATA AND
DOT BEEN TO THOSE DEMOGRAPHICS
THAT ARE SO DRASTICALLY. NEED
THOSE RESOURCES BELIEVERS TODAY
ABOUT GETS STILL WHAT WAS
ALREADY STUDY AND CARING FOR
THOSE RECOMMEND THE OUT OF THE
STATE. HEY AND YOU. I READ
REVELATIONS THE OF A CALIFORNIA
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF THAT THEY
WILL. HANDLE THIS PROPERLY BUT
I'M WILLING TO GIVE THEM A
CHANCE- AND THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING FOR ME THANK YOU
CENTER. CENTER CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I TOO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I FULLY
SUPPORTED. HAVING LOST A CLOSE
FRIEND JUST LAST WEEK A SUICIDE.
MY VIEW IS THAT RAISING THE
VISIBILITY OF BOTH THE CRISIS
AND THAT THERE ARE PATHWAYS
SUPPORT IN REMEDIES WE CANNOT
RAISE THAT VISIBILITY HIGH
ENOUGH IN MY VIEW- AS CITED BY
MY COLLEAGUE. THE RISE IN THE
SUICIDE IS ALARMING A LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND IF WE SAVE ONE LIFE
IF WE SAVE FIVE LIVES IT IS
WORTH THE PURSUIT. EVERY LIFE
IS VALUABLE I TAKE IT. TO THE
OPPONENT WHO SAW TO COMPARE
THIS EFFORT. TO THE END OF LIFE
OPTION ACT WHICH WAS DESIGNED
AS AN OPTION FOR PEOPLE WITH A
TERMINAL ILLNESS. A LIFE ENDING
ILLNESS ARE NOT SURE TO. THEY
ARE ALREADY FACING DEATH SO I
DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR
COMPARISON I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN ALL
THE ALLIES IN ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO HAVE EMBRACED THIS PATHWAY
AS A MEANS OF TRYING TO GET A
HANDLE ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EPIDEMIC OF SUICIDE. THAT IS
EXACERBATED BY THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS I STRONGLY URGE
AND I VOTE THINKING. THANK YOU
LESTER TANTO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I KNOW I KNOW THE TO.
MANY OF YOU HAVE HEARD FROM ME
BEFORE ABOUT HOW MY SENATE
DISTRICT HAS THE HIGHEST RATES
OF YOUTH SUICIDE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FRESNO AND KERN
COUNTIES BEING THE TOP COUNTIES
IN THE STATE WHICH LED ME LAST
YEAR TO. AT LEGISLATION SB
THREE THREE ONE WHICH WAS SO
START PREVENTION PLANS. IT
DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH BUT I
KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
TIME I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT. YOU KNOW. WHY I AM SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S REASON BEHIND IT AND
IT'S A MAJOR MAJOR ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT BUT I PERSONALLY COME
ACROSS IT IN MY HOMETOWN.
EARLIERTHIS YEAR AS WELL WITH
A LOVED ONE IN MY FAMILY. AND I
JUST YOU KNOW THINK THAT
WHATEVER IT TAKES WHATEVER IT
TAKES WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN PREVENT BECAUSE
IT'S ONLY INCREASING ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
CONVEYED. AND YOU KNOW I THINK
IT'S- AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
REMEMBER UNITY. BE NICE TO ONE
ANOTHER TO TREAT EACH OTHER
WITH RESPECT AND NOT JUST HERE
BUT THEN THE STATE CAPITAL AND
HIS COLLEAGUES IN. BUT REALLY
JUST A REMINDER TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS SOMEONE THERE FOR YOU.
DO NOT BE AFRAID TO REACH OUT
OR TO REACH OUT TO SOMEONE A
COMPLETE STRANGER A LOVED ONE A
COLLEAGUE YOU NEVER KNOW- BE
PATIENT AND PRACTICE PALM. IT
BE NICE TO AND SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND HAPPY. TO SUPPORT YOU.
TODAY OKAY. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COMMITTEE. OKAY BUT OKAY I
THINK IT'S A VERY BY US IN
RUBIO THANK YOU CENTER MY-
ASSEMBLY OF MY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD BY.%
EIGHT YEAR ADVOCACY- ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE I MAKE
NOTE THAT THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF A RECOMMENDATION I
CAME FROM A REPORT FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION- I KNOW
WE'VE TALKED A BIT ABOUT SOME
OF THE ISSUES I KNOW THE CENTER
MELENDEZ REYES ABOUT. THE
MULTIPLE EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE HOW WE'RE GOING TO BRING
THEM ALL TOGETHER SO. AS AS
WELL AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE. LOOKING INTO THAT
WORKING ON THAT AS WELL AND IT
CERTAINLY IS THAT. THE
RECOMMENDATION CAME FROM MY-
BURKE FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE OVER SO CAN. THAT AS-
PUBLISH THIS OFFICE AND- WITH
THAT- CERTAINLY I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN IN
CLOSE I WOULD JUST WANT TO
REITERATE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO START MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF GETTING THE
SUICIDE RESOURCES OUT THERE TO
OUR COMMUNITY. AND TO
REITERATE- WATER POLICY SENATOR
HER FATHER SAID BE KIND TO ONE
ANOTHER NO ONE KNOWS WHAT
PEOPLE ARE FACING IN THEIR
LIVES NO MATTER WHERE THEY'RE
AT. IT'S TIME TO RISE UP AS A
STATE. TO TAKE NOTE OF I DON'T
HEALTH INSTITUTE VENT. INPUT IN
THE FOURTH ROW WE TALK ABOUT
REBUILDING AN ECONOMY WE CANNOT
REBUILD AN ECONOMY UNLESS WE
START TO DEAL WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN UPSTATE. AS
A- THE START TO MOVE RIGHT.
AGAIN IF PUTTING THIS TO. AND
REESE. FOR LOCAL REGIONS AND
DIFFERENT TASK FORCE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND IT SAVES. ONE LIFE
THAT IT WAS WELL WORTH IT.
WOULD THAT. I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. AND WOULD BE
HONORED- TO ADD ANY POLL
AUTHORS FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGAIN I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF TO-
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS. THE AGAIN
THIS IS AB AT TWENTY ONE TWELVE
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER RUBIO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I AND SALAS NINE AND
SALAS FIVE GROWTH DORADO I
DON'T AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ AYE
MITCHELL. MITCHELL AYE MONNING
NINE MONNING AYE RUBIO. RUBIO
HIGH. OKAY THE BILLS OUT EIGHT
ZERO THANK YOU RIGHT IT'S VERY
MUCH SOME AROUND THIS RIGHT THE
NEXT ITEM UP IS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN BY
SUMMER KALRA. WELCOME. SO THIS
IS ON HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS
AND HEALTH INSURERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS IN ORDER TO TRACK
MARKET TRENDS ON HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND COST
SHARING AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO SUBMIT ARGUED
REPORTING FOR PLANS OFFERED IN
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETS. THIS
CONSIDERABLE ANSWER HEALTH CARE
COST PROJECTIONS IN THE WAKE OF
CARBON NINETEEN AND ITS AFFECT
ON HEALTH INSURANCE RATES.
POLICY AND PURCHASERS NEED A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF OUR STATE'S
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETPLACE TO
SHED LIGHT ON HOW CONSUMERS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES OUR PURCHASING
HEALTH. UNCOVERED CAL FOR OFF
CHANGE ON THE OPEN. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN IS NEEDED H. OF
HEALTH HEALTH. FOR IN THE IN
THE BILL AS GROUP MARKETS
POOREST. TO CHANGES IN PREMIUM
PREMIUM AMOUNTS ON THE-
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
FURTHER CLARIFY TIMING ISSUES
AND DEFINITIONS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH INDUSTRY
STANDARDS AND A LOT OF. LARGE
GROUP RATE REPORTING. AND HE
HAS TATTOO TREES AND THE BILL
ARE DELAYED IMPLEMENT. UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A NEW
REPORTING PROVISIONS THAT ARE
NOT IN EXISTING WEIGHT BALANCE.
THIS BROWN'S WORKLOAD CONCERNS
DURING DEPEND- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND THE NEED TO OBTAIN
ACCESSIBLE DATA TO ASSESS THE
STATE ISURANCE MARKETS IN THE
WAKE OF THE PANDEMIC. MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS PERCHING PURCHASING
HEALTH INSURANCE NEED ASSURANCE
BOB THE THAT THEY'REGETTING
VALUE FOR THEIR PREMIUM. THAT
IS WHY SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
THAT UNDERSTANDS HEALTH
INSURANCE TRANSPARENCY IS.
IMPORTANT TO COMBAT AGAINST
SKYROCKETING INSURANCE RATES.
YES MA'AM PLAN ON TELEPHONE
REPRESENTING HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA. THANKS VERY MUCH AS
A MEMBER AND I SO I APOLOGIZE I
MISSED THAT PARTY PRESENTATION
ARE YOU ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO THE
WITNESS TESTIFIED SUPPORT TO
YES MEN- BILLET FROM HEALTH
ACCESS SHE ON THE LINE. YEAH
ALL RIGHT GIVE ME YES WHAT
WOULD YOU GO AND BEGIN. GREAT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GETS ME
PALETTE WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION IS
THE SPONSOR OF EIGHTY TWO ONE
ONE EIGHT. AB TWO ONE ONE EIGHT
ENSURE CORRECT REPORTING
SPECIFICALLY IN THE INDIVIDUAL
AND SMALL BUSINESS MARKET
RESEARCH ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION CALIFORNIA. SO THAT WE
GET A GOOD PICTURE OF RATE
INCREASES INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE FACING BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA INTO THE OUTSIDE
MARKET OFF EXCHANGE THE CODE
NINETEEN HAD DONE THAT COULD
LEAD TO ECONOMIC CRISIS WHICH
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO RAISE FOR
YOU BECOME. THE SMALL. WELCOME
IT YOUR COMMUNITY INPUT BEFORE
A LARGE RATE INCREASES OR
CHANGES ARE MORE AS WE ALL.
YOU'LL BE TODAY FROM THE HELP
WHAT DO TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
PETER STORYBOARDING WILL BE OF
THEM. WITH MILLIONS OF CAL
LOSING THEIR- AND THEIR FOR
THEIR JOB HEALTHCARE. WE MUST
BE HOW HEAT DETECTING THANK YOU
YEARS WE HAVE OFFERED THE
AMENDMENT AND THE NOW IN
RESPONSE TO THOSE CONCERNS
INCLUDING DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA GROUP AFFORDABILITY
COST. HEALTH INSURANCE. WE ARE
STILL BLIND KEY IN. ABOUT WHAT.
PEOPLE HAVE. THANK YOU LETTERS.
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY. THANK THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITIONAL BE WITH THE- SCENE
ONE AT THE GAS LET'S MOVE TO RE
ONE TWELVE. SEEN ON THIRTY MIKE
FROM ROOM TWELVE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE. MODERATOR
PLEASE. OPEN UP THE LINES AND
CALL FOR SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN HEALTH
SERVICES HEALTH CARE SERVICES
PLANS. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEARCH.
NINE ONE FIFTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ISSUES.
MY ONE FIFTY DROPPED. NINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND
EIGHTY ASK ON BEHALF OF THE
NCAA'S CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. TWENTY NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PLEASE SHARE MEMBERS
THERE ARE FLOCKS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN. TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
BENJAMIN TRAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MY SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
FLORIAN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
IN LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. REBECA GONZALEZ
NASH OF SOCIAL WORKERS ELLO
CHAPTER TWO FOUR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINALLY THE CALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA CLIENT
CARE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS CRISSCROSSED WITH THE
TRANSITION A COALITION AND
OTHER SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN LINE ONE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE TO TEN OUT HERE
WITH THE FOUNDATION IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB
TWENTY. EIGHTEEN IS A GOOD
START FOR THE TOBACCO KICKER
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE YEAH
WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
FOR A FREE SHEET THAT NEXT
WITNESS. IF THEY DID A FEW MORE
FOR THE LINE NUMBER TO. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE FIND
ONE FIFTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
FIFTY NINE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS CALL TO
OPPOSE YES- THIS NOT WORRY TWO
MONTHS AGO WE- APOLOGIZE WE ARE
ACTUALLY. YOU'RE. OKAY WE ARE
KERN HEARING AB TWO ONE ONE
EIGHT THAT'S ALL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PLANS AND WE'RE TAKING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF OUR
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS BILL YES WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO MORE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ANGELICA
CARDIOME COMING FROM THE
TRANSLATE INTO COALITION NINE
FROM FORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN MY- MIND ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAMILLE
I'M ALSO CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THANK. OKAY THANK YOU
WE ARE HEARING AB TWENTY ONE
ONE EIGHT RIGHT NOW SO THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN AGAIN THIS
IS ON HEALTH SERVICES PLANS. WE
HAVE NO COMMENTED YOU AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE TWO WITNESSES THE
WITNESS AN OP TO TESTIFY JEFF
HAMPTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS AND
STEPHANIE WATKINS FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
LET'S BEGIN WITH. A MISTER
HAMPTON. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MR
SHARON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I JUST CAN'T DEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS READ WE AN OPERA.
THE BILL UNLESS IT IS AMENDED
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS OF THE BILL
FOR WORKING WITH US IN THE FACE
TO DRAFT SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
AND IN DO APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE ON
THIS BILL TODAY. RIDLEY WE ARE
STILL CONCERNED THAT THE THERE
WERE. HEALTH PLAN. SHOULD
PROPOSED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
BEGINNING IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR THE RATE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HELLO WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR DELAYING
THE NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
LAID OUT IN THE BILL. THE
TWENTY POINT THREE. WE ARE
STILL CONCERNED THAT THE
REMAINING PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL MUST BE IMPLEMENTED SOONER
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THERE ARE
VARIOUS FACTORS AND
CONSIDERATIONS THAT GO TO THE
RATE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. AND
MANY OF THESE FACTORS HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTER OR IMPACTED
BY THE CURRENT ENDEMIC. I WHICH
MAKES OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE MISSION DATA PART OF THE
JOB CHALLENGING HEALTH.
INSURERS DIFFERENTLY THESE
CHALLENGES FROM ALL AROUND THE
FACT THAT HEALTH PLAN RATE
FILINGS ARE DONE PROSPECTIVELY.%
HELP PLAN WILL BEGIN PREPARING
THE REDEVELOPMENT. PROCESS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO RATE THAT ALL.
AND YET ARE STILL ESTIMATING.
THE TRUE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
WILL HAVE ON FUTURERATE. I WE
BELIEVE THAT THE FULL
REPERCUSSIONS OF THE PANDEMIC
ON HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN FULLY
REALIZED AS OF YET. CONSIDERING
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
TWENTY TWENTY THREE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR THE
ENTIRE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
WOULD ALLOW ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THE NECESSARY. TIME TO ASSESS
THE IMPACT. FURTHERMORE ALLOWED
PARTNER MANAGE HEALTHCARE AND
APARTMENT INSURANCE. TO OBTAIN
AND ANALYZE MORE TYPICA MORE
TYPICAL USING DATA FOR RATE
DEVELOPMENT- AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS PROJECT FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL- I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
WORK WITH AND- WILL MOVE.
FORWARD THANK YOU FOR.
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. FIRSTLY I
THINK KERRY LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
APPRECIATE AUTHOR HIS STAFF AND
SPONSORS WILLING TO WORK WITH
THAT. UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
REMAIN OPPOSED MARKET MENDED
WHEN RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED
THOUGH IMPLEMENTATION DATE
PEOPLE EIGHT. ADDITIONALLY THE
UNDERSCORE MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENT. WE ARE UNIVERSALLY
CONCERNED WITH THE TIMING OF
THE BILL I DON'T EVERYONE OUR
MEMBERS ARE STRUGGLING WITH HOW
IT IN. ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES ALSO MEETING
THE DEMANDS OF THE HEALTH CARE
MARKET AND ENSURING THAT ALL
CONSUMERS. ENROLL YOU CAN SURE
THREE KEEP THE QUALITY
CHARACTER BASIS- HAVING SAID
THAT- WE FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE- WRONG TRYING TO ADD
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS YOU ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED WILL BE
DELAYED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. PEOPLE THAT WILL GIVE
EVERYONE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
TH PROFITS AND PLATE. AND NOT
AND DO WE TAKE AWAY RESOURCES
FROM THE CURRENT CHALLENGES
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. MEMBERS ARE
FACING. WITH THAT THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE UNDERSCORE
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR
DOCTOR AND STAFF. WITH THAT. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO KEEP OPEN. THE
BILL FOR TODAY IMPORTS WE WERE
NOT OPPOSED. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
MUCH FOR YOUR TEST NOW LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESS AND PAPA. WHO
BY NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION WE'LL START WITH THE
GALLERY. SCENE ON APPROACHING
FROM THE GALLERY LETS GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SAME KNOWN
APPROACHING IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S MOVE TO THE TELEPHONIC
LINES MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL FOR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO AB. TWO
ONE ONE EIGHT ON HEALTH
SERVICES PLANS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WANT TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A B. TWO ONE ONE
EIGHT TO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE CONSIDER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TO OPEN MY NUMBER
ONE FORTY FIVE ONE FORTY FIVE
PROVIDED OPEN. ONE FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EXACTLY YES
MA'AM. ALL RIGHT HI MY NAME IS
REGINA MENDOZA I AM CALLING IN
THE PER OF TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
YEAH. IN CUBA WE ARE STILL ON
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHT THIS IS ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PLANTS BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
PLEASE WAIT UNTIL WE GET TO
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THEY'LL
COME LATER. EDITOR OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN AGAIN ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PLANS. I
WANT TO CREATE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS CHLOE I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AYE
AYE YUP WITHIN ABOUT THE NEXT
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I-
POINTING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN OKAY.
EQUITY FUND. YOUNG SEES ME
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE NOT YET GOTTEN TO AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN WE ARE
STILL TAKING OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY TO AB TWENTY ONE DAY
EIGHTEEN. AGAIN THIS IS ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PLANS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE IF IT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ONE
EIGHT EIGHT ONE EIGHT ONE. OKAY
AND ONCE AGAIN THIS WEAPON FOR
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
I'VE NO ONE SHOWED UP ADDITION-
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH MODERATOR LET'S NOT
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
HOW ARE THEIR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN. RUBIO. YES THEY RUBIO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND I
KNOW THIS IS VERY SIMILAR TO A
BILL THAT- WE WERE THAT WE
VOTED ON LAST YEAR WHICH I
SUPPORTED IN AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR MY FOLLOWING QUESTION SINCE
INFORMATION WITH VERY QUICKLY
AND I THOUGHT I HEARD
CONFLICTING INFORMATION WITH
THE CALLER IT QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR FOR ME I THERE IS
AWESOME QUESTION AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION AND I KNOW THAT
THAT WAS AN ISSUE- AND I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW IF THAT WAS PART
OF THE AMENDMENTS I THOUGHT I
HEARD HIM SAY THAT THEN I HEARD
CONFLICTING INFORMATION- HER
FIGHT OUT FOR. THE SENATE
REJECTED. THINKING SHE OF. YEAH
THERE'S GOING TO BE- THIS
AGREEMENT TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ON NEW REPORTING
PROVISIONS THAT ARE NOT IN
EXISTING RATE FILINGS SO FOR
THOSE KINDS OF THE REPORTING
PROVISIONS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
EXISTING WE BALANCE MEANS THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE DATA. THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THAT NFORMATION THAT IS GOING
TO BE THE SOONER TIMELINE- BUT
IT BUT- WE HAVE AGREED TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION ON- ON A NEW
RECORDING PROVISIONS ON A NEW
OBLIGATIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR WORKING RALLY HARD TO. TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT WITH SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION TO AND- WITH
THAT I WILL MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE BILLS BEING
MOVED BY SARAH RUBY ARE THERE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SAYING NINE- SO MEMBER ACTOR
RIGHTS ONE THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE AND
ADDRESSING- MANY OF THE ISSUES
I KNOW STAY OPPOSITION STILL
THERE BUT- THE PROGRESS YOU'VE
BEEN MAKING IT APPRECIATE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU TOOK-
ANSWER WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MEASURE I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE WORK BUT-
BOTH OF. YOU AND YOUR STAFF
COMMITTEE STATUS BUT IS PUT
INTO WORKING WITH MY STAFF. ON
THIS AND OTHER SIMILAR BILLS IN
THE LAST COUPLE 5RS.
APPRECIATE OPPOSITION IN
WORKING WITH US THROUGH THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS THE NUMBER OF
THESE BILLS EVEN. WHEN WE CAN
ALWAYS COME TO AGREEMENT
THERE'S ALWAYS CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE. APPRECIATE THAT THE
PRESIDENT FAST WHEN I VOTE.
OKAY THANKS FOR MUCH AS A
MEMBER. SO AGAIN THIS IS AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS A- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I CAN. I
CONSULT I. FURTADO HI. TODD I
LAY. HI LEYVA I MELINDA'S.
MILLAND NO MITCHELL. BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
MONNING AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO HI.
SEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ONE THANK YOU AND THE
SUMMER KARA I UNDERSTAND YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY
SOME MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YES ALL
RIGHT WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN THANK YOU THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN SHARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE MAIENSCHEIN I WANT TO
BEGIN. MUMBAI ON HIS BACKUP
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS. AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR REPRESENTS
AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
CONTAIN SKYROCKETING HEALTH
CARE COSTS. EMPLOYERS THAT
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE BENEFITS TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES STRUGGLE TO
CONTAIN COSTS AND OBTAIN THE
BEST QUALITY OF CARE. THIS BILL
PROVIDE TWO PILOTS ONE INCIDENT
IN THE SOUTHERN PORTION OF THE
STATE. ANOTHER THE NORTHERN
SECTION. OF THE PERIOD OF FIVE
YEARS. THE PILOTS WOULD INCLUDE
RESTORING PROVIDERS THERE A
MANTRA FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE FOR
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY AND
OPERATIONS. SELF FUNDED
EMPLOYER PLANS WOULD USE RISK
BASED AUDIT RISK BASED OR
CAPITATED PAYMENT MECHANISMS
WITH THE HELP PROVIDERS FOR
THEIR SERVICES. RATHER THAN
PURE BE FOR SERVERS BONTA
STATION. AT THE END OF THE
PERIOD THE PARTICIPANTS REPORT
ON THE OUTCOMES OF THE TWO
PILOTS TO INFORM LEGISLATURE ON
PROMISING BULLS. OF CARE SING
AND DELIVERY. A STUDY BY THE UC
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PREDICTED THAT THIS TYPE
OF BOTTLE COULD REDUCE
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES BY AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED TEN BILLION
DOLLARS. OVER TEN YEARS. THE
PROVIDES FOR CONSUMERS. THE
BILL LAZOR A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMPONENTS SUCH AS ACCESS TO
SPECIALIST PRESCRIPTION
BENEFITS AND A COMPLAINTS
PROCESS THAT MUST BE CONSIDERED
AS PART OF THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS. FOR THE PILOT PROGRAMS
IS ALSO A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TRANSPARENCY AND A WHOLE LOT OF
REPORTING- THAT WOULD E
REQUIRED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE ALTHOUGH
THIS IS A MY BILL ACTUALLY LIKE
IT A LOT. SO I THINK IT DOES
ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
TRY SOMETHING NEW AND
INNOVATIVE IN OTHER IN THE
REALM OF SKYROCKETING HEALTH
CARE COSTS COMBATTING UNSTABLE
HEALTHCARE COSTS. REQUIRES NEW
WAYS OF THINKING AT LEAST PART
OF PROGRESS CAN HELP US
DETERMINATION METHODS OF
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BUT IS
STOPPED WHAT SHE SHOULD THE
GALLERY I BELIEVE AND ON THE
PHONE IS LARA JOSHUA GENERAL
MANAGER OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
THE BUCK. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT IT IS
THEIR PARTICULAR ORDER I
DIFFERENT ORDER ON MY SHEET
THAT WE CAN START WITH THIS
COLLECTION WE HAVE MISTER WHICH
IS. PHYSICALLY HERE AT THE
CANNES LIONS OKAY HE IS HERE
OKAY SO- ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH- MISS
TO WATCH AND THEN FOLLOWED BY-
LORD JOSH BUT BELIEVES UP THE
PHONE LINE SO THE SWITCH. WILL
ALSO MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBER
SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. THE STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL IN WESTERN SEES COUNCIL
TREATMENT WORKERS CO SPONSOR OF
THIS VERY. INNOVATIVE BILL.
DOES THE BEGINNING TIME ARE
TAPPED HER UNION TRUST FUNDS
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO. A
CONTRACT. WITH PROVIDER UNDER
FOR SAY. HE FOR SERVICE BASIS.
THIS BILL IS. PROGRAM VERY
INNOVATE. ALLOW OUR TRUST FUNDS
TO DO SO. ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS. WE BELIEVE THAT SINCE
THIS BILL PREVIOUSLY PASSED
THIS COMMITTEE WITH NO NO
VOTES. WE'VE ACCEPTED SEVERAL
VERY IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD YOU. THAT A CONSUMER
OMBUDSMAN BE. A CREATED BY OF
OUR TRUST FUNDS THAT THEY- THEY
TRUSTED KNOWLEDGE YOUR PRODUCE
SHIRI RESPONSIBILITY. AND THAT
THEY SUBMIT APPLICATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE BUT WITH THESE CHANGES WE
WOULD PLEASE URGE A- I HAVE A
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO- LORI JOSH
FROM CAL SCHOOLS FEVER ON THE
PHONE. PERFECT AMY YES YES
AGAIN PLEASE BEGIN OKAY PERFECT
THANK YOU THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHAIRMAN DR PAN AND
BOOK ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MAIENSCHEIN AND CAROLYN. LORD
JOSH GENERAL MANAGER OF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE GOD WORK PRIME CO
SPONSOR AND AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. CALIFORNIANS WILL BE A
PROVIDE HEALTHCARE FOR
EDUCATION AND PUBLIC AGENCY
EMPLOYEES OF THE NONPROFIT
TRAPPED UNDER INTERNAL REVENUE
CODE SECTION FINAL WOULD BE
NINE. WHAT CAN BE USED THE
BETTER OF OUR FROM UNLIKE ANY
OF THE OTHER PLAN NO WAY IS
BROWN THERE'S NO DISTRIBUTION
OF EARNINGS AND EXCESS RESERVES
MAY NOT BE RETURNED TO THE
EMPLOYERS ARE GOVERNING BOARD
OF DIRECTORS REPRESENT EQUAL
VOICES OF BOTH LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT WITH REPRESENTATION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AND THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AS WELL AS OTHERS
ALONG WITH SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT AND COUNTY
BUSINESS OFFICIALS. OUR MISSION
IS SIMPLE TO CONNECT OUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE HIGHEST QUALITY
AND MOST AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
POSSIBLE. BY USING TRUSTED
SOURCES LIKE THE OCCUPATION
ADVOCATE NIGHTSHADE COST AND
QUALITY ACCESS. AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WILL GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO DIRECTLY CONTRACT
WITH THE BACK OF THE BACK
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CREATE EFFECTIVE.
INTEGRATED IN CONSUMER CENTRIC
WORKS. I MEAN FOR THE PILOT
PROJECT HINGED BEEN IMPORTANT
THE COSBY NINETY CRISIS IS
TAKEN AT THE- HEALTH HOLD ON
BOTH THE- AND HEALTH OF OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR AND EDUCATION
WORKERS. MAKE IT IMPERATIVE TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABLE ACCESS BOTH
IN PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES BUT MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. BY GIVING
OUR MEMBERS ACCESS TO THE BEST
CARE POSSIBLE WE CAN ENSURE
WORKFORCE REMAINS READY AND
ABLE TO SERVE THE PUBLIC GOOD.
NOT ONLY THAT WE PROJECTED
SAVINGS FOR EMPLOYERS BEING IN
THAT ACCESS. A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. I BELIEVE.
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSUMERS. THANK
YOU VERY. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WILL BEGIN
WITH THE GALLERY- SEEN OTHER
WITNESSES UP IN THE GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
FINO WITNESSES COMING BEFORE I
CAN REMOTE TWELVE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINES. SO
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR- PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BREMBO CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROCESSING A SUPPORT POSITION
ON AB ONE ONE TWO FOUR. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SARA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHARE AND MEMBERS
BILL BARCELONA REPRESENTING CO
SPONSOR AMERICAN MUSICIAN
GROUPS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE ONE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
DOCTOR ADAMS PHONE WITH THE
LOYAL CARE HEALTH SYSTEMS
BRITISH SPENDING HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER IN THIS PILOT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. TWENTY FIVE RELATED
MELVIN. JULIE KELLY PROVIDENCE
ST JOSEPH HEALTH CARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS RACHEL PALOS
WITH HERITAGE PROVIDER NETWORK
OF PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROJECT. AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
CAN STORED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE COALITION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR AND I WISH TO THANK-
CHAIRMAN PAN THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR APPROVAL OF AB AT THAT
CREATED THE HEALTHCARE PAYMENT
DATA REVIEW COMMITTEE THANK YOU
TYLER PROGRAMMING LEVIN TWENTY
FOUR WILL BE HEALTHY THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO WE'RE JUST
TAKING NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. MY FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS DOING
WHITTINGTON WITH BEAVER MEDICAL
GROUP AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DON REVEREND
WITH OPTUM HEALTH CARE I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE ONE TWO FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
COUNTRY COULD WATCH ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY ABLE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MARIN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU'RE WIDE OPEN. MY
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NO RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
LITTLE TOO HELLO CANYOU HEAR
ME HI THIS IS PRETTY CROWDED
WITH BROWN INSOLENCE ADDITION
BUT WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE ONE TWO FOUR. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARYLAND I
REPRESENTS OUR RECENTLY MEDICAL
GROUPSOUR COMMUNITY MEDICAL
GROUP AND SHARP HOSPITALS IN
SAN DIEGO AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DAVID JOYNER REPRESENTING HELD
POSITIONS MEDICAL GROUP HI I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT. WITNESS LINE
ONE O ZERO IS OPEN. THIS IS
BRAD BUYERS WITH PROBLEMS
HEALTH NETWORK CALLING STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN POINT FOUR.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEVER
MIND ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR A
BI ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AFTER TIME. AND
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE WANTED A
PORTRAIT CONTINUES THERE OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR
LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAD THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES NEXT
LOUISA'S FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS IF YOU
COULD PLEASE BRING HIM ONLINE.
YEAH THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICK LOUIS THOSE WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS- IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR. IS
IT AUTHORIZES PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WILL PLACE CONSUMERS IN
THE STATE OF AMBIGUITY AS IT
RELATES TO THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE WE RANGERS OPERATES
UNDER THIS BILL PLEASE
CONSUMERS AT RISK BY
ESTABLISHING AN UNFAIR
COMPETITIVE PLAYING FIELD.
BETWEEN PROVIDER ENTITIES UNDER
RESTRICTED LICENSURE AND OUR
MEMBER HEALTH PLANS. BY DOZENS
BY ALLOWING RESTRICTED LICENSE
FEES TO ACTUALLY HEALTH PLANS
BUT WITHOUT THE SAME KNOCKING
REQUIREMENTS ARE FULLY LICENSED
PLANS FOR FINANCIAL SOLVENCY
DELEGATION OVERSIGHT QUALITY.
CLAIMS PROCESSING OTHER
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. WHILE THE
REEDS BASED PROVIDER ENTITIES
THAT CAN OPERATE UNDER THESE
PILOT PROGRAMS CURRENTLY COMPLY
WITH SOME FINANCIAL SOLVENCY
REQUIREMENTS THE LOCATIONS ARE
NOT AS HIGH AS THOSE FOR FULLY
LICENSED HEALTH PLANS. THE KEY
ISSUE A MEASURE COMEDIAN ALEX
IS A DEFINITELY POINTS OUT
FINANCIAL STANDARDS HAVE
PRIMARILY BEEN PUT IN PLACE
BECAUSE OF A HISTORY. OF METER
PROVIDER GROUP CONSULTANCIES.
WITHOUT A LICENSE FULL SERVICE
HEALTH PLAN INVOLVED IN THE
ARRANGEMENT. AND SHOULD ANY OF
THESE NEWLY ESTABLISHED
ENTITIES BECOMING COLD AND ARE
THE ONES WHO WOULD ACTUALLY BE
HARMED BECAUSE THEN THERE WOULD
BE NO ENTITY TO PAY THEIR
CLAIMS OR- PROVIDE CARE TO THE
MEMBERS. GENERALLY SPEAKING
WITHOUT A SPONSORED PLAN
INVOLVED PROPOSED HIGHLY. WOULD
SIDESTEP THE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS GUARANTEED IN THE
KNOX KEEN ACT- TO ROWLEY THAT
ALL LICENSED HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS WHICH WAS ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS THAT THIS BILL
WAS VETOED LAST YEAR. SO THIS
STORY IS TOO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS AT THE WRONG TIME.
IT'S A BIG AND IS ESSENTIALLY
SIMILAR BILL WAS. DEBATED IN
VETO LAST YEAR. BOB FOR THIS
ISSUE TO SUDDENLY MATERIALIZED
AGAIN IN THE FINAL THREE WEEKS
SESSION IS QUESTIONABLE FRO A
PROCESS PERSPECTIVE. AND DOES
NOT GIVE US AMPLE TIME TO
CONSIDER THE RISKS TO
CONSUMERS. I MISS IT ESPECIALLY
PRECARIOUS TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THESE ARRANGEMENTS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE IMPLICATIONS
ON ALMOST EVERY FACET OF- OUR
ECONOMY AND SOCIETY SO FOR
THESE REASONS COUNTLESS OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHER OUT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITIONAL BEYOND
THE GALLERY. I DO NOT SEE WHEN
APPROACHING THE MIKE FROM THE
GALLERY WAS MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IS APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE SO LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINES. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AN OLDER LINE NUMBER
ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BASEBOARD IF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COULD BE HIM JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WITH THE
GREATEST RESPECT FOR THIS
AUTHOR ME THAT LIKE THE PAIN
CAN KICK BACK IN THE FUNDS
THERE FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS. TO
HEAR CONCERNS. WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE INTERVENTION
HELPED COSTS AND IMPROVE
VALERIA AND WE WERE JUST
CHECKING ON OUR NEIGHBORS SORRY.
HE'S MADE. THANK YOU FOR JUST
LONG TIME OKAY THANK YOU YEAH
WE'RE TAKING NAMES ORGANS IN
DOES A SO THANKS SO MUCH I NEXT
WITNESS INOUR- TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED LINE IS UP. THANK YOU
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO. HELLO MY NAME
THURMOND OPPORTUNITY NO
COLLISION ON EIGHT EIGHT TWO
TWO ONE HOME RIGHT- WE ARE NOW
HEARING AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
SO. AT THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THIS IS ON
HEALTH CARE THIS IS ALSO ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
JUDICIAL OPPOSITION. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
K. SYNC UP CENTER HURTADO. I'M
OF THE BILL OKAY AND IF I
CENTER TODD OKAY SAYING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
SEPTEMBER KERR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PRESENTING BEHALF OF A
SIMILAR MAIENSCHEIN. I KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE-
LOOKED INTO FOR APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT- CENTER MANSION HAS
DONE. TO TRY TO DRESS MADE
ISSUES THIS IS AN EFFORT AT
INNOVATION- WORKING WITH THAT
TRUSTS I CERTAINLY DO HEAR THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ABOUT.
PROTECTIONS BUT I THINK WE TRY
TO PUT SOME GUARDRAILS AROUND
THAT IN THIS BILL. AND SO WITH
THAT CERTAINLY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. BUCKLEY HAS BEEN
OVER THINKING SURE THANKS VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT. SIR THIS IS AB
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR HAS MOVED
CENTER TADO TO MOTIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL. HEY HI. I CAN. I AND
SALAS GROVE HER TADO. I TARA I.
AYE LEYVA AYE MELINDA'S. MITCH
MITCHELL I MONEY HI MY NAME AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO I. THE BILL'S L.
SEVEN ZERO THANKS VERY MUCH
DECEMBER RIGHT- I SEE SUMMER
RODRIGUEZ WELCOME SO WE'RE
GOING TO NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. ON. EIGHTY THREE
TWO TWO FOR AS BY SUMMER
RODRIGUEZ WELCOME. THANK YOU
SENATOR THE MEMBERS AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FORWARD CREATE A
PROCESS TO EXAMINE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE ISSUES
IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE C. H. TO CONTRACT WITH
AN APPROPRIATE PENALTY TO
EVALUATE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADEQUATE
STAFFING LEVELS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. THIS
WOULD AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS CAN PERFORM DAILY
ACTIVITIES ARE PREVENTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND DURING TIMES
OF EMERGENCY. ADEQUATELY FLEX
TO ME COMMUNITY NEEDS. OUR
CURRENT PANDEMIC IS A TIME
EXAMPLE OF THE NEED FOR THIS
TYPE OF PLAN. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO ENSURE. CITY PH TO CONVENE
ADVISORY GROUP TO OVERSEE AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
EVALUATING ENTITIES. AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES TOWARDS TO
RECOVER FROM COVER NINETEEN. WE
NEED TO RE EXAMINE HOW LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
STAFFED AND RESOURCE. THIS BILL
IS COSPONSORED BY THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SEIU. TESTIFYING TODAY DOESN'T
SHOW GIVEN FROM THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION
ALAMY SANCHEZ FROM SEIU. THANKS
ARE MUCH SEVEN MEMBER- THAT'S
NOW MOVES TO OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES WHICH I BELIEVE ARE
BOTH ON THE PHONE LINES AND THE
CHAU GIVENS. FROM JACK AND
LIVVIE SANCHEZ WILL BEGIN WITH
THE THIS GIVENS. HERE ON THE
LINE. EIGHT EIGHT YES I AM%
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON HERE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHELLE
GIVEN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE AT
THE BEACH CALIFORNIA AND ONE IN
THE HOUSE BECAUSE I'M THROUGH
THE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY TWO FOR
A COMPANY HE HAS JUST ONE
ILLUSTRATION OF HOW PUBLIC
HEALTH GRANT AN IMPACT THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ADVERSELY IMPACT FACTORS
FACTORS IN THE ECONOMY AT
LARGE. LOCAL PUBLICHEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THE FIRST LINE
OF DEFENSE AGAINST THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GRANT AND WE WORK
TIRELESSLY TO PREVENT OUTBREAKS
IN THE PRIDE IN OUR COMMUNITY%
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ALL THE
WORK HE REDUCED PRICESDAYS THE
OF THE IN OUR- AND ALSO
ADMINISTERED EIGHT AIMED AT
PROMOTING HEALTH EQUITY AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT WE
RELY ON TRAIN PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SUCH AS THAT THE
KNOWLEDGE IT. EVEN BACK THE
GATORS PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING
LABORATORY IN AND HEALTH
EDUCATORS TO NAME A FEW AND
THAT'S WORKFORCE NEED TO
CONTINUALLY INVESTED INTO.
HOWEVER LOCAL HEALTH. I COULD
NEVER GET A CLIENT AND STATE
AND FEDERAL. AND ACCORDING A
RECENT REPORT BY THE TRUMP
AMERICANS HEALTH. PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS IN OUR NATION HAS BEEN
UNDER FUNDED BY FOUR POINT
BILLION. WE AFTER IT WENT
PUBLIC WORK THAT THE BALL. ANY
HAD IT EASY THEY'RE NOT PUBLIC
HEALTH ADEQUATELY STAFFED
STRONG. ISN'T IMPACT. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE BITCOIN
NINETEEN ACTUALLY REVEALED THE
NEED TO FURTHER UNDERSTANDABLE.
INFRASTRUCTURE EIGHTY THREE TO
DO FOR WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONTACT WITH APPROPRIATE AND
EQUAL VALUE WAIT THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT ALSO
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS THAN FOR
ANY FOR. THE EVALUATION WHAT IT
WOULDN'T MATTER PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. HELLO IDENTIFICATION
OF BARRIERS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. BACK IN A
LITTLE DEPARTMENT. AND ALSO.
THAT THE EVALUATION OR AFFECT
THE I THINK IT'S OF OUR
INFORMATION FOR. EVALUATING
PUBLIC LABORATORY CAN. AND
ABOUT RESEARCH TRIANGLE FEDERAL
FUNDING PROVIDE AT THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ANAL WORK OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AT THE-
EIGHTY THREE TO FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE A PORT AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF FIGHTING.
PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE IT.
THE VALUE IN WHITE IN GAS AND
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF LOCAL.
REBEKAH THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I NEEDED FOR THIS
REASON THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR EFFORT ON EIGHTY THREE
DIGITS FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND WITNESS- THE CENTERS AND
YOU HAVE JUST SLIGHTLY UNDER
TWO MINUTES. HI IT WOULD BE
FAIR HAS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
EMPLOYEES AT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC OF
COMMERCE ANYTHING GOES BE
INVALUABLE ROLE PLAYED BY
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT HAVE. PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WORK DAY IN AND
DAY OUT WITH DRAFT ARMY NUMBER
OF THE INDIVIDUAL AND COMMUNITY
NEEDS TO BE ADDED WITH CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND WE ALL
KNOW MANY CURRENT CONDITIONS
SUCH AS ASTHMA DIABETES
HYPERTENSION AND OBESITY HAVE
EXACERBATED THE ATTACK THE POPE
IN NINETEEN PARTICULARLY AND
ECONOMICALLY DISENFRANCHISED.
COMMUNITIES IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC PUBLIC FROM HAVE THAN
RESIDENTS OF TOWN BUT IMAGINE
WHERE WE'D BE AS A STATE ALL OF
OUR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FOR ADEQUATELY
RESOURCE AND STAFF. THIS BILL
WILL TAKE AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD AFTER PAINTING THE NEEDS
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITYBASED
ARE. THAT WE ARE FAR BETTER
PUT. ANY AND ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
IS. WE THREE AND FUTURE THANK.
THANKS FOR MUCH WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES WHO
ARE AND SUPPORT. BY NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE GALLERY SCENE
KNOWN APPROACHING AT THE
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM. ONE
TWELVE SEEN ON APPROACHING IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINES SO
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
AND CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AB THIRTY TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OPEN MY NUMBER TWO ZERO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE CAN'T
KEEP BIRD WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA CREDIT BECAUSE
MONSTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MY EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MEMBERS
BENJAMIN TREND THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. TWO ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT NOTHING
CANNOT HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AND NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
ONE. MY APOLOGIES ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY
FIVE RELATED OPEN. MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN I'LL BE OUT THE
BOARD SUPERVISOR SAMPLER COUNTY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT ONE IS. TWO ELEVEN YEAR IS
OPEN. THE COLD WAR NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. TWO OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTERNOON DONNA THANKS
FOR VISITING ABOUT THE END OF
ACCOUNTING FOR THE SUPERVISOR
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
LYING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND HUMBLED AND
SOLANO BUT THE TRANSPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING JEREMY DATE.
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOHN LEVEL ON THE HALF
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. ORSON OFFICERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON THE BOARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION-
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS INDICATED SO WE WILL GO
TO THE GALLERY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR SAYING
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. THING
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
COMING UP TO US AND OPPOSITION
LET'S MOVE TO TELEPHONIC LINES
MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES IN CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU.
SHOW UP. FOR AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME. AND
I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION- THANKS VERY MUCH.
THAT LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE CENTER
MINING. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I JUST WANTTO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND-
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
ALL THE EMPLOYEES OF OUR-
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH. AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BOTH IN THE FACE OF COVE IN
NINETEEN. PANDEMIC AND ALSO
THAT KNOWLEDGE THAT DAY TO DAY
WORK. THE STATE AND COUNTY
EMPLOYEES TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM. OTHER DISEASE
OUTBREAK AND- THE INVESTMENT
NECESSARY TO PREVENT CHRONIC
DISEASE REDUCE INCIDENCE OF
CHRONIC DISEASE THROUGH
EDUCATION AND HEALTH PROMOTION.
LET'S SUPPORT THIS BILL I'M
GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO I GUESS THERE'S A
MOTION BY CEREMONY I CENTER
TADO. THANK YOU PICTURE JUST TO
REQUEST THE AUTHOR AT TWO PM
YOUR CO AUTHOR OF HIS BILL.
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. HOW DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THAT DECEMBER OF
ROOM MORE THAN HAPPY TO ACCEPT
HER AS WELL I THANK YOU SORRY
TO CUT YOU OFF THERE OKAY I SEE
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I JUST WANNA SAY SUMMER. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND ALSO CHAIR OF
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE HEALTH
SERVICES AND ACTUALLY ASK THE
DEPARTMENT ON SEVERAL DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS ALTHOUGH THERE'S BEEN
SOME CHANGE OF LEADERSHIP I
GUESS EARLY SHIFT LEADER TO
CHANGE AGAIN. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE I BELIEVE
THERE WASN'T A SAYS IT WAS DONE.
ONLY ABOUT. AGO AND- THE BIRD
GOOD. TO HELP US SAYS THIS
CONTRACT ME. BUT IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME AND CLEARLY WE NEED
TO STRENGTHEN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. EVEN BEFORE CO
THEY BOTH COVERED WE CERTAINLY
THIS IS A COME TOP OF MIND. IT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT INITIATIVES
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE IN
THIS BILL. AND CERTAINLY GOING
TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. OF
THIS AND SO LIKE. TO CLOSE. I
CAN ASSURE FOR. RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK THANKS VERY MUCH SO.
AGAIN THIS IS A- THIRTY. TWENTY
MOVED BY CENTER. MINING THAT
MISSION. FAST APPROPRIATIONS
THREE PLEASE CALL ALL. HANDS I
CANNOT HIDE AND SALAS HI. SALAS
HELLO I. KNOW I LEYVA. ABOUT HI
MELINDA HI. MULLIN AYE MITCHELL
ALL MINUTES I'M NINE MONEY
RUBIO. RUBIO HI. BILLS OUT
EIGHTY THANK YOU PRICE THIS
SOME NUMBER CARILLO HERE- SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB THREE THREE THREE SIX
BY THE RECREO ON- THIRD PARTY
FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE. WELCOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I AM PROUD 2% ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX A
CRITICAL BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AGAINST FOOD CONTAMINATION FOR
FROM READY TO EAT DELIVERY
SERVICES BY ESTABLISHING
PRINCIPLES SAFEGUARDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX WHICH MY OFFICE HAD
BEGUN WORKING ON BEFORE
COVERAGE EIGHTEEN. TITANS EVEN
MORE NOW IN LIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE NEW REALITIES
WE'RE LIVING IN THIS PLASTIC
SHIELD MY FACE MASK SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND OF COURSE
SHELTERING IN PLACE. AS WE HAVE
ALL SEEN HOME FOOD DELIVERIES
HAVE ROCKETED US RESTAURANTS
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO SHUT DOWN.
AND THE PUBLIC WAS ORDERED TO
SHELTER IN PLACE. HOWEVER READY
TO EAT FOOD DELIVERIES HAVE
ENABLED MANY RESTAURANTS. MANY
IN MY COMMUNITY TO REMAIN OPEN
FOR BUSINESS DURING THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TIME MAKING IT
PROBABLY THE ONLY WAY THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO STAY. IN
BUSINESS AB THREE AT THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX WILL ENHANCE
FOOD SAFETY ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH IS PARTICULARLY CRITICAL
AT THIS TIME. IN AN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS ISSUES RAISED BY THE
OPPONENTS I HAVE POSTMAN'S TO
REQUIRED TO BE MAINTAINED. AT
THE HOLDING AT THE HOLY RETURN
US TO PREVENT SPOILAGE. SPECIFY
THE FOOD FACILITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO CLOSE THE BAG OR
THE CONTAINER WITH THE TAMPERED
EVIDENCE. SEVERED AND OTHER
CLARIFY CHANGE. READY TO EAT
DELIVERY DRIVERS AND RESTAURANT
WORKERS HAVE BECOME ESSENTIAL
WORKERS SUMMIT COVERT NINETEEN.
AND WESTERN ALLIES EVERY DAY TO
FEED CALIFORNIANS. THESE
WORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL NOT
SACRIFICIAL. THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH BY ENSURING
THAT READY TO EAT FOOD IS NOT
TAMPERED WITH. A NO BRAKES
STEEL OR OTHER METHOD OF
CLOSURE- IS A PROPERLY USE ON
THE CONTAINER OR THE BACK. END
IS DELIVERED BEFORE COME BECOME
SPOILT. IT PROTECTS THE
INTEGRITY OF THE FOOD PROVIDED
BY RESTAURANTS WHERE THE FOOD
IS PREPARED. AND IT ENSURES THE
EIGHTY OF AMHERST. BECAUSE THE
PONYTAIL SOME IN THE ARE SEVEN.
WITH THE KILL RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND JUSTIN MALANDA
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
OUR MENTAL HEALTH ADMINISTRATOR
SO I BELIEVE ON THE LINE. THERE
WE GO RIGHT THANKS RAJ SEMI
MEMBER- LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- SO WE
HAVE- JUST IN MILAN ON THE
PHONE FROM AND ALSO MATT SUTTON
SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH MISTER
MILAN. TO GAIN- DID AMANDA
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HEARING THIS BILL- AS THE OLD
THE STATUS AND OUTLOOK
COMMITTEE AND I WORK WITH.
CORRECTLY IDENTIFYING THIS IS
BECOMING EVER MORE IMPORTANT
WITH THE CODE ENDEMIC. THE BILL
HAS CONCEDED ARE. YOU GOING
BACK IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
RESPOND ASSOCIATION AND THEY'RE
VERY PLEASED TO. MOVE FORWARD.
I WANTED HER TO QUICK BECAUSE
AT REYES SOMETHING HE SAID
CONCERNS WERE FOR A BY OF THE
TWO GROUP THAT RUN TO ACT. AND
I JUST WANTED TO REITERATE WHAT
THE OLD OUTLINE. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A GREAT MOST IF NOT ALL OF
THESE CONCERNS WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE THE BILL SIMPLY TO COMPLY
WITH YET STILL MAINTAINING A.
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTION. ALL OF THE VEHICLE
BE AND CLEAN THE BILL. REMOVES
THE COMBO OF THE RIGHT THAT OUR
CURRENT IN. CALICO'S HOUSE BILL.
WE ALSO I WONDER STRESS THAT
WE'VE TRIED MAKE IT. BY GIVEN
WOULD BE ARE YOU DELIVERY
SERVICE. THE LATTER YOU WITHOUT
HAVING TO FOLLOW NECESSARILY
SOME OF THE COMMERCIAL
STANDARDS. BUT THEY WILL HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE FDA GUIDANCE AS
TO HOW TO PREVENT SPOILAGE AND
THEN FINALLY- THE NEW YORKER
MENTIONED THIS ONE OF THE OTHER
POINTS RAISED BY A TECHNICIAN
OTHERS IS THAT THIS BILL IS
INTENDED. TO PROVIDE SOME
CLARITY OF EXISTING LITTLE WHAT
I'LL THIS BILL THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WILL HAVE
TO RELY ON CHILDHOOD IN ITS
CURRENT FORM AND COLOR CODED
CAL CURRENT FORM IS READY
WRITTEN. FULL COMMERCIAL
TRANSPORTATION SO WE SEE THIS
AS A AS AN ACCOMMODATION UP
WHAT IS HAPPENING THESE THESE
PRIVATE VEHICLES BEING USED BUT
IT DOES PROVIDE A CRITICAL PART
XIN. THANK YOU PROOF. PACKAGING.
AND. THIS BILL THANK THE
OPENING OF STAR WORKING. OKAY
THANK YOU AND NOW LET'S MOVE ON
TO MISTER SET AND YOU HAVE
ABOUT A MINUTE FORTY FIVE
SECOND. THANK YOU DOCTOR IF
YOU'RE SURE THAT AT SEVEN OF
THE CAL REST ASSOCIATION THE
HEAD OF WHO IS RIGHT FROM THE
MY WHO COME IN THE DOOR
RESTAURANT IN THE LOWER DOCK.
ALL THROUGH THE PREPARATION
PROCESS NAKED THE COOKING AND
EVENTUAL THE FOOD CAN YOU AND
YOUR CAN. BUT THE BASIC IN
STATE GUIDE DO NOT EXIST FOR
THAT DELAY. SO WHAT DID DOES
THAT SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE HOUSE
RESTAURANT CHAIN DO THE ALL
MANDATORY TRAINING ON COULD AND
DO BETTER PRACTICE. BUT SOME
PUBLIC DOES FOR TO. OUR LAW
ABSENT FROM LIVE LANDSCAPE. AT
THE ASSEMBLY WILL STATE THAT.
THE INTERNAL CLEANLINESS OF THE
ACTUAL VEHICLE SO THIS IS ABOUT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS FOR THE
REMAINING STATE AFTER THE
FIFTEENTH THE RESTAURANT AND
BEFORE YOU OR YOUR CONSTITUENTS
RECEIPT THAT FOOD REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERYMUCH LET'S
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION WILL BE GIVEN THE
GALLERY. SCENE ON APPROACHING
AT THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. VENONA
BROACHING IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S MOVE TO THE TELEPHONIC
LINES MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX. YES PLEADED
GENTLEMAN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE'LL OPEN
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY NINE TO
TWENTY YEAR WIDE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA THANKS FOR
BEGINNING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. THANKS VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. DOMINANT REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU TO
SHOW SUPPORT. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO-
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE TESTIFYING. CAMERON DEMETRI
FROM TECHNET I WOULD PRONOUNCE
IT CORRECTLY AND DYLAN HOFFMAN
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH. I CAN'T RUN
IF WE CAN BRING- CAMERON ON THE
LINE. SHARE AND MEMBERS GET
RECOGNITION WOULD. WE SHARE THE
AUTHORS GOAL OF ENSURING THE
SAFE DELIVERY OF STUDENTS I
BELIEVE THE REQUIREMENT OF A
TAMPER EVIDENT BAGS HELPS
ADDRESSES BUT UNFORTUNATELY
TECH NOT REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED TO EIGHTY THREE THREE
THREE SIX. HE HAS WORKED WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR JIM
COULD BE ADVOCATES YET THIS
BILL BUT WE STILL HAVE AN
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT REMAIN
WE HAVE AUTHORED AMENDMENTS
OVER A. OVER A MONTH AGO AND WE
FEEL. EITHER REASONABLE COMP
AND STICK IT AT. AND THE INTENT
OF BILL. PLEASE CLARIFICATION
DELTA'S TO DELIVERY REST BUT
THE MAJOR SURE THAT. RUSSIAN
ARE DOWN. IN GROCERY STORE OPEN
UP AND OF GOVERNMENTS. ALSO
CONCERNS I NEED REQUIRED OF THE
BILL I THINK THAT SECTION. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN NINE NINE SIX
OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
WHICH ESTABLISHES THE THIRTY
MINUTE DELIVERY REQUIREMENTS.
WE BELIEVE THIS SECTION OF CODE
IS MORE APPLICABILITY
COMMERCIAL TEMPERATURE
CONTROLLED TRANSPORTATION. THAT
SECTION OF CODES. REFERENCING
THE TRANSPORTATION OF RAW SHELL
EGGS AND I'M SHOCKED AND LYFT
MOLLUSCAN SHELLFISH RATHER THAN
TEMPER TEMPERAMENT AND FUTURE
BAG OF CHICKEN TENDERS AND
FRENCH FRIES. WE HAVE PROPOSED
AN ALTERNATIVE AMENDMENT THAT
IS ALSO IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE CHANGE INDUSTRY
WHICH IS MORE APPROPRIATE FOR
THIRD PARTY FOOD DELIVERY CLASS.
I MEMBERS ARE NOT IN THE
BUSINESS OF MAKING CUSTOMERS
UNHAPPY. FOR PROVIDING THEM
WITH FOOD THAT IS NO LONGER
SAFE WE OPERATE IN A
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT
ENSURING RELIABLE AND SAFE FOOD
IS PARAMOUNT TO OUR ABILITY TO
RETAIN SATISFIED. CUSTOMERS
MOST OF MY RIDER UNDER THIRTY
MINUTES BUT THERE MAY BE CASES
WHERE DELIVER HAS A LONGER
DELIVERY DRIVER. PARTICULARLY
IN RURAL AREAS THE REQUIREMENT
OF THIS BILL COULD POTENTIALLY
LEAD US NOT DELIVERING TO THESE
AREAS. OF CONCERN OF NON
COMPLIANCE WHICH IS AN AREA
CODE IT BECOMES. PARTICULARLY
TENUOUS. POSITION THERE IS A
NEW AUTHOR AMENDMENT THAT
REFERENCES THAT THE FOOD SHALL
BE MAINTAINED AT. HOLDING
TEMPERATURE NECESSARY TO
PREVENT SPOILAGE MINISTERING
BUT WHAT IS YOUR NAME AND
INTERLINK ENFORCEMENT
EDUCATION. IS DISCOUNTED TO THE
PREVIOUSLY REFERENCE SECTION
WHAT TEMPERATURE DOES THIS.
MEAN FOR EACH POTENTIALLY
TRANSPORT FOODS BUYER DELIVERS
THIS BECAUSE THEY GIVE ME. AND
TO BE. ACTED ENFORCEMENT.
LASTLY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
CHANGE IN THE WAY MEMBERS
REFERENCE KERN DOLLAR US. THIRD
PARTY FOR DELIVERY. BUT WE
WOULD LIKE IT'S INSTEAD TAKE
THIRD PARTY. RT DELIVERY AND
HOW ARE COMPANIES ARE TYPICALLY
REFERRED TO FOR THESE REASONS
AND OTHERS OUTLINED THERE ARE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TECH THAT
REMAINS ONE OF BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT IN ANY POSITION AND LOOKS
FORWARD TO FUTURE PROTECTED
CONVERSATIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO- DYLAN HOFFMAN AND
THEIR ASSOCIATION IT'S CLEAR
LEFT YOU ABOUT A MINUTE AND SIX
SECONDS. RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN CENTERS OKAY THAT'S
BASED ON HOW OFTEN DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT SERVICES
INTERNET ASSOCIATION- WE
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED ON A. B. THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX. I GREATLY
APPRECIATE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE AND
SPONSORS AS WELL THEY MIGHT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN US FAR HOWEVER
AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED THERE ARE
SEVERAL OUTSTANDING ISSUES I
REMAINING- INCLUDING SOME OF
THE VEHICLE REQUIREMENTS- FROM
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROVISIONS- BACK. IN AFFORDABLE
TO- READY TO EAT OR PRINT
DELIVERY- HAVING- WE ALSO ASK
THAT ADDITIONAL PARTY- BE
PROVIDED- REGARDING THAT THE
TAMPER EVIDENT PACKAGING AS
WELL AS THE LINE THE BILL- TO
ONLY APPLY TO RESTAURANTS-
PREDICT THAT ALIGN THAT WITH
THE BILL STATED INTENT PROVIDES
GREATER CLARITY- SO FOR THOSE
THREE. YEARS CAN. YEAH. THE
PROPOSAL MUST NOT TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS IT IS A STATE
THANK YOU FOR MUCH ANALYSIS ON
TO OTHER WITNESS AND UP NAME
POSITION WILL BEGIN GALLERY
SAYING ONE AT THE GALLERY MOVE
TO ROOM ONE. SAY NO ROOM ONE
TWO TEST IN OPPOSITION LET'S
NOW MOVE TO THE LINE A
MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES A CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN CHAU OPPOSITION
FOR EIGHTY THIRTY THREE THIRTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I'VE
NOTING JUDICIAL OPPOSITION FOR
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH NOW LET'S MOVE IT TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES SIR
TARA. DOES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANTED JUST TO EXPRESS-
CONCERN THAT I HAVE WITH WITH
LEGISLATION I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY BUT AT EIGHTY IT
BEGETS NECESSARY AND NEEDED I
THINK THERE'S- I MEAN I EVEN
YOU KNOW WONDERS MYSELF
SOMETIMES A IN TERMS OF
DELIVERING OKAY WORK ONE
HUNDRED. YOU KNOW BEN IS IT ALL
HAVE BEEN THERE FOR. SO IF YOU
YOU BRING FORWARD A LEGITIMATE
AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED ESPECIALLY NOW DURING
COVERT. HOWEVER I DO WANT
EXPRESSED YOU KNOW ON THE
RECORD MY CONCERN FOR THE- IN
COST FOR POSSIBLY FOOD- AT A
DELIVERY I DON'T KNOW IF THERE
IS THAT EXPECTATION OR ARE YOU
ASSUMING THAT THERE MAY BE. OF
INCREASING AND COSTS FOR FOOD
THAT IS BEING DELIVERED. I MEAN
I DON'T KNOW THAT ANSWER BUT IF
YOU HAVE AN ANSWER. IT YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT AT
LEAST ON MY NECK I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
THINKING ABOUT IT. IN TERMS OF
HAVING A CONCERN BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR LEGISLATION
TODAY. SEPTEMBER T. WISH TO
RESPOND TO THAT. I CAN RESPOND
TO MY CLOSING AT THAT OKAY ONLY
CARRILLO TAKEN CLOSE ALRIGHT
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND TIGHT YOU KNOW I
WANT TO THINK THAT THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FLORIDA BUT I
ALSO EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS-
UNFORTUNATELY WE ALL KNOW HOW
CONDENSED THIS SESSION HAS BEEN
AT IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE
DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING THIS BILL AND YOU KNOW
AS A LAST WEEK IT CAME UP AND-
YOU KNOW I PRIDE MYSELF IN
REALLY DOING. MY DUE DILIGENCE
AND REALLY HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO A TO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND REALLY
DELVE DEEP INTO JUST
INFORMATION AND CAN I SET OUT
TO DO SOME RESEARCH ON THIS
ISSUE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE AND- AND IT'S NOT YOU
KNOW OF COURSE IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT. CONCEPT DURING
COOLEY NINETEEN THAT WE PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND THAT WE ARE VERY
MINDFUL OF TRANSMISSION AND ALL
THE ISSUES THAT COME WITH IT TO
BUT I WAS TRYING TO FIND. DATA
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS TYPE
OF BILLS PRIOR TOCOVER
NINETEEN AND- AND I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THERE'S ANY INFORMATION
OUT THERE THAT CAN HELP
WITHOUT. SOME DATA THAT SHOWS
HEALTH PROBLEMS FROM THESE TYPE
OF DELIVERY SERVICES AGAIN IN
TERMS OF JUST UNDERSTANDING THE
BIGGER PICTURE AND DIE HAVE
CONCERNS ALL FILLED WITH SOME
OF OUR BUSINESSES AND I'M NOT.
GONNA BILLS AS A UNTIL LIKE THE
GROCERIES ASSOCIATION ANOTHER.
BUSINESS WE CAN BUT MY LITTLE
BIT TO CONSTANTLY ARPINO WITH
ME EVERY. TO CHECK UP LET HIM
BREATHE A LITTLE FEEL THERE'S
MUCH CA THEIR WAY AND THESE ARE
COMPANIES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO. TO TAKE A PAUSE AND RE
ROUTE AND REDO THINGS RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE JUST IN SURVIVAL MODE
AND DA. NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW
IT WORKS- QUITE FRANKLY I'VE
HAD VERY LITTLE TIME TO EXPLORE
THIS ISSUE GIVE ME A LITTLE
PAUSE AGAIN I'M NOT THINKING OF
THE BIG COMPANIES THAT I KNOW
OKAY HANDS BUT IT'S LITTLE
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT WHO
ARE REPEATING FOR SUPPORT AND
HELP. RESURFACES HAVE BEEN THE
ONLY LEAD WHEN THEY'VE LOST.
OFTEN AND I AND I KNOW WE SHARE
SIMILAR. THE AUTHOR I AND SO I
CLEARED UNDER. HOW I IS BUT I
WANT TO JUST ALSO SAY I WILL
SUPPORT IT WITH RESERVATIONS
AND I REALLY WANT TO. YOU KNOW.
GET MORE INFORMATION ON THIS
AND EXPLORE IT FURTHER AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I
STATED BILLS CONCERNS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER MONEY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I WANT
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND ALSO TO APPLIED.
HER WORK TO SIX SUPPORT OF THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ALONG
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS. CLEARLY THE
SELF INTEREST OF RESTAURANTS
WHO TAKE PRECAUTIONS AS WAS
STATED FROM THE- DELIVERY OF
FOOD TO THEIR STAFF ASSESSMENTS
TO THE PREPARATION. AND NOW
SENDING OUT. THEIR PRIORITY IS
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS BUT ALSO THEY HAVE A
SELF INTEREST IN BEING
PROTECTED AGAINST POTENTIAL
LIABILITY- SO THAT SWING THAT
CHAIN OF DELIVERY. HAVING
CERTAIN PROTOCOLS THAT ARE
FOLLOWED IT ACTUALLY PROTECTS
EVERYBODY FIRST AND FOREMOST
THE CONSUMER. THE RESTAURANT
OWNER AND EVEN THE DELIVERY
SERVICE SO- I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND WOULD BE
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU CELEBRATION FROM
CENTER MINING ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OKAY SAYING NINE. SUMMER I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND- SOMEONE WITH
A BACKGROUND PUBLIC HEALTH I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL TO ENSURE THAT WE KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE. OFTENTIMES PEOPLE
TAKE FOOD SAFETY FOR GRANTED
AND- I APPRECIATE THE SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT THE TECH
COMMUNITIES BROUGHT UP BUT- I
ALSO WANTED. YOU'LL BE SURE
THAT WE KEEP THE FOOD SAFETY
CAN EXPECT CUSTOMERS TO SIT AND
TRY TO TRACK HOW LONG IT'S BEEN
BETWEEN THE TIME THE RIGHT NOW
WHATEVER YOU'RE PICKING IT UP
UNTIL IT DRIVES THE CUSTOMERS.
WE NOW THAT ACTUALLY THE CC
MAKES NOTE THAT ROUGHLY ONE IN
SIX AMERICANS. GET FOOD
POISONING EACH YEAR. AND
ACTUALLY THREE THOUSAND DIE
EACH YEAR OF FOOD BORNE
DISEASES. CERTAINLY I DON'T YEP
I KNOW THAT NO ONE. WANTS THAT
TO HAPPEN OR EVEN INTENDS THAT
TO HAPPEN WHEN IT COMES TO FOOD
DELIVERY. THERE'S A REASON WE
HAVE FOOD STANDARDS AND IN FACT
IT'S OUR ENVIRONMENTAL. HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
WHEN WE GO EAT WHETHER WE GET
DELIVERY OR GO TO A RESTAURANT
THAT- WE ARE SAFE. AND IT'S A
HARD JOB BY THE WAY IT'S NOT
EASY AT THAT THE REASON THAT
STILL WE STILL HAVE THE NUMBERS
I JUST CITED IS BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT AND- BUT I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE AND THAT.
THERE'S ACOSTA GETTING SIX TWO
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S LOST
WAGES ARE HEALTHCARE COSTS OR
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS. AND SO
WE NEED TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
KEEP FOOD SAFE YOU OBVIOUSLY
WANT. REASONABLE REGULATIONS
ARE WORKABLE AND I APPRECIATE
SOME NUMBER THAT YOU HAVE WORK
TO MOVE THE BILL IN THAT
DIRECTION. BUT AS A- THAT YOU
HAVE SUPPORT FROM PEOPLE WHO
ARE FAMILIAR WITH HANDLING FOOD
OR SPONSORING FOOD IS SAFE. AND
WITH THAT I CERTAINLY IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL WHICH I
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR POSSIBLE I'D LIKE TO ONE
OF THE- WITNESSES. OF TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME THE TECH.
START AND THEN I CAN DO MY
CLOSING OKAY SURE OF WHICH
WITNESS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DOESN'T ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS CAN. ANSWER SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT TECHNIC-
ALSO RAISED OVER THE- LET'S
BRING MISTER MILAN. ON THE LINE
TO- TO. FOR SOME OF THESE
ISSUES BEFORE THE SUMMER'S
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL POLL THAT
WAS COMING IT HASN'T BEEN EASY
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS AN
EASY BILLS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE AND I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU ALSO FOR WORKING WITH US IN
THE COMMITTEE FULL ACTUALLY.
CREATING AN EAGLE ON A COUPLE
OF IMPORTANT ISSUES HE. DIDN'T
COME ACROSS. IT IS VERY PLEASED
TO. IS WILL HAVE NO ADDITION
COST SECOND REDUCE CALL. FOR
MANY OF THE- DELIVERY SO.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW OUR ACTIVATED.
HELLO IS WRITTEN PRIMARILY WITH
PROMOTIONAL GROCERIES AND MINE.
IT LOOKING PRIMARILY AT
COMMERCIAL LENDERS.
PROVISIONING TRANSPORTATION WAS
WRITTEN OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO
HE DID NOT CLOSE. THE CHECK IN
THIS CODE. PERSONAL CALL USE
DELIVERY. AND ON THAT POINT WE
CHANGED THE TOO MANY IT
JENNIFER TO BE CLEAN AND OF THE
I DO NOT BELIEVE THE HELP CAN
WOULD ALLOW PROVISIONS BECAUSE
THE NET. SECONDLY THE REASON WE
NOT TAKE OKAY NOT PROPOSED TO
DEAL THAT TO TAKE THE- CHECK.
OPPOSE ABOUT CHANGE THE DATE.
WITH RESPECT IT'S THE MY OKAY
THERE ARE DELIVERY SERVICE THAT
MAY NOT HVE AN ACTING.
DELIVERY SERVICE PEOPLE BY OF
THAT OWN CAR. WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE TWO SERVICE WHETHER IT'S
ACTING ON OUR. OPEN TO TAKING
AMENDMENT TO WOULD ALLOW YEAH
THE FACE PLATFORM BUT WE ARE IN
IN OLDER. WHETHER THEY'RE ON ON.
TAKEN A OPEN IN THE JUST TO BE
CLEAR. WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS EASY TO
COMPLY WITH. ABOUT IT MONTH AGO
HEARD THAT THE PREVIOUS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL. WHICH
SAYS THE DEALER MISTAKES HAVE
TO REQUIRE CAMBRIDGE. THERE WAS
A COMPLAINT THE DEVIL TO THAT
TO FOR. SO WE SIMPLY SAY IT IS
THE- OF THE DELIVER CHAU OF THE
FOOD THAT COMES. DURING THE
TIME. HEY HEY TO DELIVER THE
FOOD FROM THE RETAIL FOOD. THE
CARD ENDING ADEQUATE GUIDANCE
IF YOU. WHICH TOOK ABOUT
TEMPERATURE COULD. SO WE FEEL
WE HAVE WORST IT'S ONE OF THE
DIDN'T TO COMMENTS OF THE
TECHNICIAN OF THOSE WE HAVE
RESPOND IN THE WAY WE COULD TO
MAKE THIS. INCLUDE AND IN
SCHOOL SO BY THELOCAL CHEN. TO
PROVIDE LIVE THE DEEPER TO THE
FACILITIES NOT ANY. AND WE HAVE
TAKEN OUT. WRITTEN OUT OF THE
BILL GROCERY DELIVERY SO THIS
IS A RARE TO EAT FROM WHATEVER
FOOD. IS TO BE FOR NEEDS TO BE
DONE I WAITING A WEEK THINK OF
US BILL. CLINTON CURRENTLY
ECONOMY OF ONE MORE RIGHT NOW
OF THE TIME OF IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY YOU BEFORE HAVE
TO SEND CLOSE GIVEN THAT
STATEMENT TODAY OTHER ARE.
SAYING ASSEMBLY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO FINISH PLEASE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO MY
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
TO THE OPPOSITION FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE.
AND TO THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT AND FIRST
LET ME JUST SAY. THIS HAS BEEN
A REALLY INTERESTING EXPERIENCE
TERMS OF TRYING TO COME
TOGETHER WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ONLY TO
HAVE MORE CONCERNS PLACED ON
TOP OF THOSE CONCERNS. ONCE
THOSE CONCERNS ARE ALREADY
ADDRESSED THAT TO ME SEEMS LIKE
A AN UNFAIR WAY TO DO BUSINESS
AND TRY TO PASS LEGISLATION
AMID COBIT. THAT ACTUALLY AIMS
TO HELP PEOPLE ARE NOT A
CONTACT AND NOT CONTRACT THE
DISEASE. AT THE TO THE ISSUES
OF A SMALL BUSINESSES. THIS
ACTUALLY IS A IS A BILL THAT
PROTECTS SMALL BUSINESSES THE
REALITY IS. THAT LOOK I USE.
THE THIRD PARTY PLATFORMS TO
GET FOOD DELIVERED FROM
RESTAURANTS- AND I HAVE IN THE
PAST YOU SEE BAGS DIED FROM A
FAST FOOD JOINT. THAT WERE
OPENED THAT WERE NOT. IN A
CONVERSATION WITH MEMBERS AND
TRYING TO EXPLAIN THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
THIS LEGISLATURE HAVE ALL SET
I'VE EXPERIENCED THAT TOO IN
FACT I ORDERED. A BURGER WITH
SOME FRIES ONLY TO NOTICE THAT
YOU KNOW MORE THAN HALF MY
PRICE OR EVEN. AND YOU BEGIN TO
THINK. WELL THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL GET INTO YOUR FOOD
THAT THEY EAT THEIR FOOD OR
THEIR HANDS CLEANED AT CETERA.
THERE WAS ONE SITUATION IN A
STORY THAT WAS SHARED WITH ME
WHICH- HE- NOW TO. PERSON
DELIVER THE FOOD AND THAT THEY-
BAGS AND BAGS OF CLOTHES IN THE
CAR. WHICH. AND THE END OF IT
BELIEVE THE FIRST PERHAPS. AND
THAT THE MONEY THAT THEY WERE
RECEIVING A JUSTIN. TO PAY FOR
THE CELL PHONE THERE WERE USING
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE PART TIME
JOB MEANING CAN YOU. THE FIVE
IN TO AN END OF THAT IS
HOMELESS THAT IS DELIVERING
FOOD AND THAT IS ALSO HUNGRY.
THAT IS A WHOLE OTHER
CONVERSATION THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH WITH THE TYPE OF
REALITY THE CALIFORNIA FACES.
BUT AMID COLD IT. WHAT IS THE
WHATARE THE CHANCES THAT YOUR
FOOD MAY BE CONTAMINATED IF IT
IS NOT SEALED. WITH THIS BILL
I'VE SPOKEN TO A LOT OF MY
SMALL RESTAURANTS TO ANSWER
SENATOR RUBIO'S POINT ABOUT
YOUR SMALL BUSINESSES. WHEN YOU
ORDER FOOD THROUGH A PLATFORM
AND THE CUSTOMER IS NOT
SATISFIED THEY DON'T GO ONLINE
AND COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
PLATFORM. THE GO TO YELP AND
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE RESTAURANT.
AND THE RESTAURANT HAS NO
IMPACT TO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THAT FOOD IS DELIVERED AND THE
AND THE INDIVIDUAL THAT HURTS
THE MOST IS THAT RESTAURANT
BECAUSE THE FOOD HASN'T BEEN
SEALED OR DOESN'T HAVE A SOME
KIND OF FIELD. TO AVOID ANY
ISSUES IN THE RESTAURANT IN MY
COMMUNITY AND MY DISTRICT THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT I HAVE
SPOKEN TO. THEY LIKE THE IDEA
OF BEING IN CONTROL. OF
PREPARING THE FOOD PUTTING THE
FOOD IN A CONTAINER IN THE BACK
SEALING IT WITH A STICKER OR
WITH STAPLES. AND THEN HANDING
IT OFF TO SOMEONE ELSE TO BE
DELIVERED THAT ENSURES THAT
THAT FOOD IS NOT CONTAMINATED
IT IS NOT TAMPERED WITH AND THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO RECEIVES IT.
RECEIVE THE FOOD THAT THERE ARE
INTENDED TO RECEIVE THAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL- IT ALSO
REQUIRES THAT- VEHICLES ARE
CLEAN. AND CLEANABLE TO THE
EXAMPLE THAT I JUST GAVE YOU WE
HAD ORIGINALLY INCLUDED HOT
FOODS FROM GROCERY STORES I
LOVE A GOOD ROTISSERIE CHICKEN
WHO DOESN'T RIGHT. AND THE- AND
THAT IS AVAILABLE AT THE
GROCERY STORE. WHERE YOU CAN
ALSO BUY OTHER TYPES OF FOOD.
NOW IT GETS COMPLICATED WHEN
YOU ORDER. OF HOT FOOD LIKE A
ROTISSERIE CHICKEN OR A
SANDWICH FROM THE DELI INSIDE A
GROCERY STORE. SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT OKAY MAYBE THAT'S A LITTLE
COMPLICATED LET'S LOOK AT THAT
LATER AND WE EXTENDED IT. SO TO
CONTINUE T SAY THAT. OUR
GROCERIES ARE IMPACTED THAT IS
COMPLETELY. ARE NOT TRUE WE
HAVE WORKED REALLY HARD TO MAKE
THIS BILL BE APPROPRIATE BILL
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
THE CALIFORNIA STANDARD. NOT A
LOCAL JURISDICTION BUT A
CALIFORNIA STANDARD FOR
DELIVERY OF SAFE FOOD SO THAT
IF YOU ARE HOME. IF YOU ARE A
SOMEONE THAT IS A POTENTIALLY
COULD BE IMPACTED BY COLD IT
BECAUSE OF YOUR AGE. OR OTHER
TYPES OF SCENARIOS AND IF YOU
HAVE YOUR FOOD DELIVERED. THEY
USED TO GET THE BEST SAFEST WHO
DELIVERED. TO YOUR HOME THAT
THE RESTAURANTS- MAINTAIN THE
QUALITY THAT THEY INTENDED TO.
AND THAT THE PERSON DELIVERING
THE FOOD CONTINUES TO HAVE A
JOB AMID THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
IS THE INTENT OF THE BILL THAT
IS WHY WE WORK ON IT SO HARD.
THAT IS WHY IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
NOW THAN EVER BEFORE. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST
ARRIVAL. THANK VERY MUCH THAT.
THIS IS A THIRTY THIRTY SO THE
MOTION I THINK WAS IT WAS IT
MADE BY CENTER YES CENTER
MINING TO MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HAN HI CAN I GONZALEZ HI SALAS
I GROW FURTADO. I TOTAL AYE
LEYVA HI. DAVE I AM MELENDEZ
NO. MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
MONNING AYE RUBIO. RUBIO I.
SEVEN THE BILLS OUT SEVEN ONE
TWENTY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. AND
I SEE WE HAVE SUMMER SANTIAGO
RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TWO ONE
EIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO TESTIFY ON
THIS- SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF INTEREST IN THIS WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS- I
WILL TRY TO BE AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLEUNDERSTANDING YOU'VE
BEEN HERE ALL DAY BUT IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL TO US.
I AM VERY PROUD AUTHOR AND THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE MEDICAL AND MENTAL. AND
DIRECT PURPOSE WHAT THE
SERVICES. ARE FOR THE TGI
COMMUNITY. AS AN ALARMING RATE
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH CARE FOR
THE TGI PEOPLE IN OUR STATE AND
THEY'VE ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED
BY COVERT NINETEEN. S. BATTLE
THAT WE PROVIDE SERVICES. FOR
GDI COMMUNITY TO ACCESS TO
PROPER HEALTH CARE ESPECIALLY
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SHIPP
MISTER CHAIR. AND I HAVE A HAVE
A TWO WITNESSES THAT WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO PRESENT BRIEFLY IF
YOU'RE OKAY WITH A MIXTURE. YES
THIRTY NINE OKAY SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MEMBER- WE HAVE-
TWO WITNESSES SET TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF BELIEVES THEY ARE IN
HAVE- ME- WHEN YOU WIN HERE
OKAY SO- MICROPHONE BELIEVES
OVER THERE YOU CAN COME OVER
THERE- AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
THAT MANY EVA HARPER. AT HERE
OKAY THERE YOU ARE ALL RIGHT SO
WE'LL HAVE- THE WHEN FIRST
TESTIFIED THAT JUST KEEP IN
MIND THERE'S TOO FEW SO IT'S A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES. I'LL
GIVE YOU A TWO MINUTE WARNING-
WHEN YOU HIT YOUR TWO MINUTES
SO JUST KEEP IN MIND AFTER THAT
YOU'RE USING YOUR PARTNER'S
TIME. AS WELL AND- SO ONCE YOU
GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE US
YOURSELF AND BEGIN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. PERFECT YES YES HELLO
MY NAME IS NEIL NGUYEN AND I'M
THE MOBILIZATION COORDINATOR.
AT THE GENDER HEALTH CENTER.
WHICH IS A TRANS LED AND TRANS
SERVING ORGANIZATION BASED HERE
IN SACRAMENTO LOCATED IN YOUR
DISTRICT SENATOR PAN. WE WOULD
LIKE TO YOU FOR THE OP. OUR
ROLE AS A TRANS LED MEDICAL
HEALTH PROVIDER ORGANIZATION IS
CRITICAL TO OUR COMMUNITY SO
MANY LOOK TO GHC AS A LIFELINE
AND AS A BEACON OF HOPE. OUR
SERVICES INCLUDE COUNSELING
LEGAL HEALTH CLINICS HEALTHCARE
CLINICS ADVOCACY SERVICES
RESPITE SUPPORT GROUPS AND SO
MUCH MORE I KNOW THAT G. HAS
HELL SO MANY OTHER TRANS
CLIENTS ALL OVER THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION. BECAUSE I WORKED AT
FRONT DESK AND CONNECTED WITH
NEARLY ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. WE MUST EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF YOUR- AND ABILITY
FOR TGI PEOPLE TO TRANSITION IS
A LIFESAVING IT. THE MEN AND A
MOST HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND IT ALLOWS TO BE ON THEIR
OWN TXTILES. WE BELIEVE IN
SELF DETERMINATION AND THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES. ANTI
TRANS RHETORIC EMPHASIZES THAT
WE DON'T KNOW OUR OWN BODIES
OUR OWN MINDS AND OUR OWN WILL
THAT THERE SHOULD BE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING CARE. WE
KNOW OUR BODIES BETTER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE. THERE HAVE BEEN.
WHERE OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
STRUGGLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
FUNDING AND PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT OUR COMMUNITY SO.
URGENTLY NEEDS THE NEED FOR A
SERVICES HAVE SKY. SINCE THE
PANDEMIC. NOW MORE THAN EVER
THE TGI COMMUNITY NEEDS THE
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATOR TO
MAKE THIS MONUMENTAL DECISION
TO ESTABLISH A REOCCURRING
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN EQUITY
FUND. WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN
SUPPORT TRANSLATE ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE OUR OWN GENDER HEALTH
CENTER AND THE FEW ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT NEED TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
A HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITY. LASTLY IT IS
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS THAT
SOMEONE THIS BILL TO DIED BASED
ON THE ILL INFORMED CLAIMS THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW CHILDREN
TO GET SURGERIES WITHOUT THEIR
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS CONSENT
TWO MINUTES. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NOTIFIED TO ALBANY EVA HARPER
TO PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. AND YOU HAVE A
MINUTE FIFTY FOUR SECONDS.
WELCOME. MY NAME IS EBONY ABLE
HARPER I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA TRANSCEND A
TRANSLATE STATEWIDE INITIATIVE
THAT PROMOTES THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I RESIDE
IN THE HONORABLE SENATOR PANTS
DISTRICT AND IT IS AN HONOR TO
BE HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT
THIS CRITICAL BILL AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I GREW UP IN SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES OFF OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWELVE IN
NORMANDY. MY MOM IS A WELL
KNOWN PASTOR IN LOS ANGELES.
WHICH MEANT RELIGION HAD A BIG
INFLUENCE ON MY CHILDHOOD I WAS
VERY AWARE OF WHO I WAS AT A
YOUNG AGE. EVERY BEING A KID
AND MY MOM HAVING THE BIBLE IN
FRONT OF ME. AND SAYING YOU
CAN'T COME INTO THIS HOUSE
UNTIL YOU PUT YOUR HAND ON THE
BIBLE. RIGHT NOW IT'S ACTING
LIKE A GIRL WITH TEARS FLOODING
MY FAITH I WALKED. OUT TO THE
STREETS. TO GO TO HOLLYWOOD AT
THE AGE OF THIRTEEN. EVENTUALLY
I DO TRANSITION. BECAUSE I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO HAIL AND
LYFT WAS. VERY HARD SO ON THE
STREETS I WAS MISERABLE NOT
WALKING IN MY TRUE SOMEONE
HAPPY SO I DECIDED TO CONTINUE
MY TRANSITION AND GO BACK ON
THE STREET. I'VE SPENT MANY
YEARS IN A ROW OF DESPAIR AND
INSTITUTIONS. THANKS TO THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND A
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR. I WAS
ABLE TO OBTAIN OPPORTUNITY
EMPLOYEE MYSELF. UP BY MY
BOOTSTRAPS AND WORK MYSELF UP
TO BEING THE FIRST BLACK TRANS
WOMAN TO WORK AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT. AND NOW THE STATE
DIRECTOR THE STATEWIDE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA CHANCE STAND
STILL DUE TO RIGHT WING ANTI
TRANS PROPAGANDA THE TRAP IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MY
LIBERTIES ARE DALY WHEN I LIVE
ANIMALS ARE DALY AFTER AT. THE
TROPICANA JUST RESCINDED
OBAMA'S TRNSGENDER HEALTH CARE
PROTECTION WE DO NOT WANT
CALIFORNIA TO FOLLOW THE SAME
FOOTSTEPS BY LOADING. I ASK
THAT THIS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS SUPPORT TRANS
COMMUNITY AND VOTE YES ON AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER
ITNESSES AND SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO ONE EIGHT- WILL
BEGIN WITH THE GALLERY- OTHER
PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY
SUPPORT ITS NAME WORKSTATION
POSITION. SAY NONE LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SAYING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE.
MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES AND CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN ON TRANSGENDER
WELLNESS EQUITY FUND. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST LINE FOR COMMENT IS MINE.
ONE EIGHTY THREE NINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
CREDIBILITY OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. YOU'RE WALKING
DON'T FIFTY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IMPORT THANK YOU THANK. YOU
NEXT WITNESS MY- NINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER KERN
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR THE
TECHNICIAN OR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER LORIEN
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. FINALLY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE BACK IN
BALANCE NATIONALIZATION OF
THOSE WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE A WITH THE TRUMP
BOOKING A COALITION AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR BABY ON
IT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT
YOUR MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRYING
BUT THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY THREE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU COULD JUST RAINY.
NINE THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY. THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE. THANK.
LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT
WITNESSES. OKAY NINE SEVENTY
FOUR EACH YOUR LINE. IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY ALEX
CALLED ON THEY HAVE THE
TRANSPONDERS VARIANT AND
INTERFAX STRUCK THE PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THANK. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS
NEAT CRAWL I'M HAVE BEEN THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT THIS.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOTHING UNDERLYING
FIFTY SEVEN NINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NADIA ALONG WITH THE
TRAVEL YOU KNOW COALITION AND
AMBLE I'M- CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO TO EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ANY OF. HELLO MY NAME
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DONNA AND
THE GRAND I AM CALLING FRONT
THE CARD IS AB TWENTY EIGHT IN.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THAT'S-
NINE TO TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY TO
TWENTY THREE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DEBBIE TRANSPLANTED DONOR AND
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
APPENDECTOMY KIDDING RIGHT-
EIGHTY TWO TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME WILL
AGUIAR-CURRY KITA AND I'M
CALLING BEFORE AND AB. TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TO FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI EVERYONE. HOW STRONG
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY
CENTER AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN DR KING AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JAMES ONE. I AM A
MEMBER OF ST JOHN'S EPISCOPAL
CATHEDRAL IDENTIFIES THE
CHRISTIAN TRANSIENT DEMAND. I'M
ALSO PROUD GRANDSON. IT'S POINT
GRADUATE. LIEUTENANT GENERAL
USING ONE AND I SERVE ON WEST
HOLLYWOOD WALKING REGION OR
COUNTRY. UNITED IN FOR THIS
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO WEEK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU X. WHAT
THIS. NINE ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. MY
NAME IS GERRY AND GOES ONE I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SOLANO SERENITY CENTER IT
TRANSLATED ORGANIZATION AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU THE
NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TRACY SALAS CALLING ON BEHALF
OF ASIANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
FOR LGBTQ EQUALITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND TRUMP SUPPORTER OF
EIGHTY TWO TO MONEY. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GONNA.
CALLING IN VOLATILITY WITH
TRAMPOLINE A COALITION AND THEN
FROM THE COURT OF AB Q. Q. ONE
EIGHT. THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
THIS. NINE THREE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE HUNDRED AND- RIGHT HI
AMANDA MCALISTER WILDER WITH A
CALIFORNIA LGBTQ HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORKING
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE SIX THREE FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS RIGHT
I'M CALLING IN SOLIDARITY WITH
TRANSPORTATION A COLLISION AND
GENDER JUST A LAKE CONSTRUCT
FOR OF AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE OR
TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ADRIAN SERRANO I LIVE
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO. HELLO MY ROOMMATE AND I
AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
DISABILITY A GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING- THE I
MIGRAINES IN THE BAY AREA AND I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT- AS AN
ORGANIZER OF THE DELAYED YET
HAS TAKEN QUITE AN EXCITING NON
BINARY- I THANK YOU HE IS ARE
JUST TAKING A NORMALIZATION
POSITION INCLUDE THAT'S A LOT
OF EXCITEMENT STRAND. LED. A
HUNDRED. I YOU HEALTHCARE IS
GOING TO COME THE QUALITY LIFE
WE EAH I. THANK YOU OF. PLEASE
WE ALL READY HOW MODERNITY NEED
MORE REPORT WE. THANK AND I'M
NOT TAKE ADDITIONAL TESTING AT
THIS. WE'VE TESTING SO WE
SHOULD NAME OR AND DOES PLEASE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT WINTER AND.
ARGUES. MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES MY NAME BECAUSE I
DON'T. AND I AM CALLING FROM
THE TEMPLATE YOU KNOW
COALITION. NAME IS TRONG
SUPPORT. AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT.
I IMPORT PEOPLE THANK YOU PLEA
AND THANK YOU SO I JUST A
REMINDER HEALTH AND MODERATOR
JUST A REMINDER THAT WE'RE JUST
WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. AND SO WE'RE JUST
HEARING NAME OR THE EDGES
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION.
AND BY THE WAY THAT WILL ALSO
APPLY TO THE OPPOSITION AS WELL
SO WE JUST WANT TO BE FAIR TO
EVERYONE SO AGAIN WE'RE AT THE
TIME WHICH IS TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
TESTIMONY HAS BEEN HEARD IN
FAVOR AND WE WILL BE THEN LATER
HEARING TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. SO NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
CRITICAL. LINE ONE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MIKEL RUNNING AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACKIE KENNEDY AND I'M CALLING
ON INVOLUNTARY WITH THE TRANS
OF PEANUTS COALITION TUESDAY TO
RALLY SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY THREE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M IN THE LATTER FROM
L. A. COUNTY I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THANK. MY TWO THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI TWO HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WATER MAINTENANCE
DOWNLOAD MCCARTY AND OTHER.
DAYS AFTER AN APPLICATION. I
AND I FINALLY LEARNED BE.
WANTING THE YOU THANKS WITNESS.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIO LOPEZ
AND I'M CALLING INVOLUNTARY
WITH TRENT LET YU KNOW
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU EXPERTNESS. MY.
TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
NINE TO WORK. VERY. CALLING
FROM THE REST LATER AND THEY
WERE WRONG. AS EIGHTY WIDE.
THANK YOU. X. WITNESS. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOE KERNEN. CALLING IN
ORDER TO TRANSLATE INTO
COALITION AND GENDER JUSTICE LA
AND SHARKS AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU EXCELLENT
THIS. NINETY EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS HOLLY TO
ANGEL I AM DIRECTOR OF
TRANSMITTING PROJECT AS WELL
AS- FORMER SENATOR OF THIS DO
YOU JENNIFER CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES. AND TRYING TO SHOW MY
SUPPORT FOR IT DOWN THE BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
THANKS WHAT S. NINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MEGAN
MCLAUGHLIN I'M CALLING ON
SOLIDARITY WITH THE TRANSLATE
YOU KNOW COALITION AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MICHAEL RIGHT
AGAIN I'LL BE OUT SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SHIPBOARD THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE THREE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME.
HELLO CAN CONTINUE IN YOUR NAME
YES PLEASE CONTINUE. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON- I'M PAYING TEN FROM
SAN JOSE AND JOHNNY ARE CLOSE
EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT OKAY
WE ARE WE ARE TAKING SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. VICTORY SHEER
TESTIMONY THIS IS NOW FOR SOME
FOR A TO TWO ONE EIGHT. NEXT MY
AND ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO. HELLO
HELLO YES PLEASE SHARE
MAIENSCHEIN AND OPEN I'M MY
NAME IS CHRIS I'M CALLING FROM
THE TRANSIT IN A COALITION AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ONE. MY HUNDRED AND
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LISA
MARIE AND I'M CALLING OUT FROM
TRYING TO CONNECT COALITION I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE.
EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NINE TO
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MAKAYLA I AM A MEMBER OF THE
LOS ANGELES CHAPTER OF THE
CENTURY THAT WE PROJECT I STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH ENTRANCE
LOOKING A COALITION AND GENDER
JUSTICE LA AND I'VE BEEN TOLD
THE COURT AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE TO THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS. ALL BY
THEMSELVES FULLER BUT EIGHT
EIGHT ANTI VERY WHICH I LISTEN
AND HOPING THAT THE BOOK OF
CALIFORNIANS THANK THANK YOU
NEXT. NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHLOE ON BEHALF OF
IDEAS ABOUT THAT THE NEXT
ORANGE COUNTY AND I- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE THREE SIXTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS. AND
I'M CALLING FROM I'M LOOKING AT
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
COUNTRY. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS IS JOB ALTHOUGH ON BEHALF
OF A COALITION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS SUPPORT SERVICES AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS BARBARA
NINE. I AN OPEN OUT FIFTY ME
WHEN YOU'LL AMY OPPOSITION WE
WILL GET TO THE OPPOSITION- AND
SHORTLY WE ARE TAKING SUPPORT
TESTIMONY AND AFTER THIS IS
COMPLETE WE WILL THEN MOVE TO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. X.
WITNESS. NINE THREE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS. THEIR
FIRST. I FOR THE CITY IN COUNTY
SANTA CLERK'S AQABA
TRANSPORTATION IS. AT WE'RE
CALLING IN FRONT FOR A TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN RIGHT THAT BUT AND THIS CALL
CAN BE CALLED IN THE- EIGHT
EIGHT ONE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE TO
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
WANT TO SIXTY FOUR. LIVING ON
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY A REGISTERED NURSE IN
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB RIGHT THANK YOU WE
ARE TAKING SUPPORTERS MILLION
ALBUM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL BE MOVING TO
OPPOSITION SHORTLY. NEXT
WITNESS. MY FOR TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
MELANIE'S SENATE AND I'M PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER I'M ALSO IN
OPPOSITION ACTUALLY YOUR AND
OKAY EIGHTY WON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE RIGHT NOW THANK
DAY THANK ONE WE HEARD YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
LET'S WE WILL BE MOVING TO THE
OPPOSITION- WE'RE TAKING ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT. BY SUMMER
SANTIAGO ACTUALLY MODERATE CAN
YOU GIVE ME AN INDICATION OF
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE ARE ON THE
LINE WAIT TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT. YEAH WE HAVE FOUR OKAY
PLEASE CONTINUE. NINE ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. SORRY NINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE DROPPED. NINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOU'RE BACK ON. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH
SH. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. MY FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANGELICA CARDIO ON THE
TREADMILL YOU KNOW COALITION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY
TWO TWO ONE EIGHT. NINETY FOUR
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLY LOCAL ALL
RIGHT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE QUOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SIX
WITNESS. NINE NINE FOUR FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING HOLDING
HORRIBLE HELP ACTIVE CALIFORNIA
AND WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. AND I LEFT MINUTE
QUEUE IS LONG BEFORE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FOUR SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO MAKE IT RIGHT. COURTNEY
WITH THE MONITORING CENTER AND
I AM CALLING ON THE BOARD OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. OKAY THANK
YOU. SIX WITNESS. WE HAVE
FURTHER AND OKAY NO FOR
COMMENTS SUPPORT NOW LET'S MOVE
ON THEN TO THE OPPOSITION I
REALIZE THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
BEEN TRYING TO GET ON THE LINES
HERE- WE MAY COME BACK IN CASE
TO CATCH ANY OTHER PEOPLE LATER
BUT LET'S MOVE NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION- IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE LAURA PERRY. FROM FOR SOME
MYSTERIES ARE THERE OKAY SO
WHAT YOU HAD TO THE MICROPHONE
THERE AND WE ALSO HAVE DR
CLINTON VAN. METER WHO'S GOING
TO BE ON THE LINE SO- KEEP IN
MIND THAT YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF
FOUR MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A
TWO MINUTE SIGNAL- THEN YOU
KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO GET INTO
YOUR- PARTNER'S TIME. WHEN THAT
BEGINS SO WITH THAT. SALON.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WHY DON'T GO
AHEAD. I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE
EXTRA TIME BECAUSE THE
PROPONENTS- RAN A LITTLE OVER
SO OKAY WHICH GO AND BEGIN.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME THE HONOR SPEAKING
TODAY. MY NAME IS LAURA PERRY
I'M A FORMER TRANSGENDER. AND I
REPRESENT THOUSANDS WHO'VE
CONTACTED ME AND MINISTRIES
LIKE MINE. WHO REGRET
TRANSITION. BUT UNLIKE TRYING A
CAREER OR NEEDS FOR
TRANSGENDERISM AS PERMANENT
LIFE ALTERING CONSEQUENCES.
MANY OF WHICH CANNOT BE UNDONE.
THE PROBLEM IS IN THE MIND NOT
THE BODY. IN MOST CASES
TRANSGENDERISM IS BIRTH OUT OF
REJECTION OR OTHER EMOTIONAL
WOUNDS. IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I
WAS ABSOLUTELY CONVINCED OF THE
MAN. AND BEGAN TAKING
TESTOSTERONE I HAD TWO MAJOR
SURGERIES INCLUDING A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY. AND AT ALL FEMALE
WORKERS ARE. THE FIRST I
THOUGHT IT WAS EVERYTHING I'D
EVER WANTED. WAS NOW LEGALLY
MAILING OUT JOB WHERE I WAS
ONLY KNOWN AS MALE. BUT
INITIALLY I BECAME MORE AND
MORE DEPRESSED. I FOUND WHAT
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS HAVE THE
TRANSITION ISN'T REAL. NOT ONLY
WAS THE TRANSITION NOT REAL.
BUT IT DID NOT RESOLVE THE PAIN
IN THE UNDERLYING ISSUES I
REALIZE ONE DAY BEFORE. THAT IT
WAS NEVER GOING TO BE A MAN.
BUT IT WAS TOO PAINFUL TO FACE
BEING A WOMAN. I GRAPPLED WITH
THE SAME THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE
THAT MANY DO AFTER SURGERY.
IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT THAT YOU
WERE IN MY SHOES HAVING
PERMANENTLY ALTERED YOUR BODY.
AND REALIZING THAT YOU HAD BEEN
DUPED. BUT THANKFULLY FTER
NINE YEARS OF LIVING IS
TRANSGENDER I WAS RESCUED FROM
THE HELL. I SHOULD BE DEAD I
CONSIDER TAKING MY LIFE. BUT
INSTEAD OUR CREATOR AND MY LORD
AND SAVIOR JESUS CHRIST RESCUED
ME. HE TOLD ME TO LEAVE IT ALL
THE- AND FOLLOW. BECAUSE IT
FIFTY TELLS US THAT HE WAS SENT
TO BIND UP THE BROKEN HEARTED.
AND THAT IS WHAT HE DID. HIS
COMPLETELY HEALED ME AND SET ME.
NOTED TO GO BACK NO DINNER JUST
FOR. FIVE BECOME SO FOR.
BELIEVE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT ARE
EVER TO. BUT I CAN'T GUARANTEE
I WAS. I IMPLORE YOU TO VOTE NO
AB. AB. TWO LISTEN CHILDREN
EVEN I EVEN TOLD HER HER. TO
PER. MAY THEIR BODIES IN THIS.
WHO COUNTS ANOTHER THING. OF
MANY GO ON TO LIVE. PRODUCTIVE
LIFE. WITHOUT TRANSIT. CURRENT
AND OR AND- ABLE TO EMBRACE THE
RIGHT IN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO- DR
CLINTON VAN METER- AND YOU HAVE
BECAUSE TWO MINUTES AND TWO
SECONDS. THE DOCTOR. IT ACROSS
IS BOARD CERTIFIED OF FORTY
YEARS BROWN PRACTICE I GO ALL
THE WAY BACK IN MY TRAINING
YOUR TO THE INCEPTION- OF
pTRANSSEXUALS IN THE TIME AT-
TREATED AT JOHNS HOPKINS
HOSPITAL- THE CONCEPT IS
IDEOLOGY NOT BASED ON SCIENCE
AND BECAUSE OF THAT JOHNS
HOPKINS I STOPPED THE PROGRAM
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND INDICATED THEY WOULD NOT
CONTINUE BECAUSE IT LACKS
SCIENCE AND WAS BASICALLY AN
IDEA. AND GENDER HAS NO
BIOLOGIC BASIS IS OF AT THE
STATE OF MIND THIRTEEN OF
THIRTEEN PUBLISHED STUDIES SHOW
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY A
MINIMUM OF SIXTY MAXIMUM 98% OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS WITH
APPROPRIATE CONSISTENT CONSTANT
COUNSELING THEY JUST FROM THERE
DISSOCIATION OF BIOLOGICAL SEX
AND GENDER BY THE END OF THEIR
ADOLESCENCE THIS IS A NATURAL
PROCESS WHICH IS BROUGHT ABOUT
BY PURITY AND PURITY DOES NOT
NEED TO BE BLOCKED. NOT IN THE
CITY'S PARKING IT IS NOT A
CAUSE YEAH ALLOWING THE CHILD
TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE GENDER DYSPHORIA AND WISH
TO CONTINUE IT IS THEY GOT
CONVAIR VALVES TO GO RIGHT INTO
MEDICAL TREATMENT WITH CROSS
SEX HORMONES AND SUBSEQUENT
SURGERY ALL OF WHICH I DO NOT
CHANGE THE PERSON ABOUT KAMALA
FEMALE OR VICE VERSA. IS THE
APPEARANCE AND THE COST WHICH
NOT THEM IN THE LONG RUN
BECAUSE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE DOUBLE THE SIZE. OF BEEN
DISPROVEN BY. STEADY AND
JOURNAL AMERICANS LIKE HIGH.
WHICH SHOWS THAT NOT ONLY
MEDICAL. TREATMENT NOT BRING
ABOUT THAT MENTAL IN THE
TRANSGENDER POPULATION BUT
SURGICAL INTERVENTION ALSO DID
NOT THE IS. LAST WEEK. BY THAT
JOURNAL AND IT IMPROVES IN THE
CURRENT STUDY THAT ALL OF THE
MYTH OF TRANSGENDERISM BEING
NECESSARY TO TRANSITION-
SOCIALLY MEDICALLY AND
SURGICALLY BRING ABOUT BETTER
MENTAL HEALTH. WHAT I'M ASKING
THIS COMMITTEE IS JUST NOT
THERE TO TABLE THIS BILL AND
BRING TOGETHER IN THE SAME ROOM
FACE TO FACE. PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE AND LISTEN
TO FINANCE WE ARE NOT LISTENING
TO SCIENCE WE HEAR OF PEOPLE
CALLING IN TODAY WE'RE
LISTENING TO MOTIONS ALL OF
WHICH ARE PASSIONATE. AND HOT
AND HIGHLY- STRONGLY FELT I
ASKED FOR A PAUSE. AND A
HEARING THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
MUCH WE HAVE NOW HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM THE OPPOSITION
WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WHO WISH TO.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AGAIN ITS NAME IF YOU HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION WITH A START IN
THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WISH TO
TESTIFY FROM THE GALLERY. SAY
NINE WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. IF YOU AGAIN JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
PLEASE. ANYBODY WILL BARGAIN I
REPRESENT THE CHANGE MOVEMENT
AND D. TRANSITION OURS AND I
STRONGLY BUT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. YEAH OKAY ONE WAS BY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER SENDS OUR
PRESENT THE CHANGE MOVEMENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
YES MY NAME IS GREG BURCH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
AND WE ARE AT OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT DOES STERILIZE. NO
THE TESTIMONY THANK THANKS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR POSITION AND ANY
OTHER WITNESSES A ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SAYING NINE I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL ONES IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE ENTER YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. HI
MY NAME IS REBECCA SMITH- AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHANGE MOVEMENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. AT PRECIADO IN KEEPING
THEIR SOCIAL DISTANCE HERE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. MY NAME IS
JESSICA OWENS AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING CHANGING MOVEMENTS
D. TRANSITION- AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. MY NAME IS AMY
LOGAN I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
CHANGE MOVEMENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND THE GALLERY OKAY AS YOU
KNOW THE WITNESS HERE. HI I'M
KEN WILLIAMS FORMERLY GAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CHANGE MOVEMENTS
D. TRANSITION- SIR NEGLECTED BY
THE BILL I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES UP IN THE
GALLERY. OKAY SAYING NONE IN
THE GALLERY LET'S MOE NOW TO
OUR TELEPHONIC LINES. AGAIN
JUST A REMINDER FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE WATCHING THIS
HEARING ON THE INTERNET THERE
IS SOMETIMES A LAG SO I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE SO- SO
HE- IN TERMS OF BEING SURE YOU
GET. WHAT THIS MORE
CONTEMPORARY IN TERMS OF THE
TIMING. AGAIN IT'S THE
TESTIMONIES LIMITED TO YOUR
NAME IF YOU'RE A WITH AN
ORGANIZATION THAT AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. MODERATOR WILL YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY TWO ONE EIGHT AND
AGAIN- JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. THANK YOU AND
LADIES. IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME F YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION AB.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. OUR FIRST
LINE FOR COMMENT IS MINE THREE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS FOR YOUR
HOME AND OUR STRONG OF THE DEAL
ON THERE ARE A LOT THINK HE AND
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH JUST
AGAIN NAY DOES. NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE.
MODERATOR. IT'LL BE JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT OF OUR NINETY
CAUGHT UP THAT'S RIGHT THANK
YOU.
ONE MOMENT. NINE TO SIXTY
FIVE. I'M SORRY ONE MOMENT. AND
OBERNOLTE LINE NUMBER TWO NINE
SEVEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IN OUR
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANKS WITNESS WE
HAVE THE RIGHT NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS LAURA
MARTIN I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. I WILL GO TO MY NUMBER
FOUR FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI A I. PLEASE IS A MINORITY OR
POSITION MIDDLEMAN YOU NAME OR
EXEMPTS THANK YOU CONNECTS WITH.
WE HAVE I NEVER SEVEN FOUR GO
AHEAD. BEFORE. SEVEN FOUR.
LEVINE TRAINING CALLING THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR TWENTY SIX YEARS
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY WHAT I'M OF
COURSE BE. AND THE STAR OPPOSE
EIGHT TWO WAY THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. YES PLEASE
THE NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLEASE. MY MOVING UNTIL NINE
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THE GROUNDS VOTER IN
THAT SENATOR PAN HISTORY SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY EVERY JOB HIM.
IN STRONG K<c.cyan>. TWO EIGHT.</c>
THANK YOU NEXT WITH. MIND EIGHT
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY BE ON THE END. YES MY NAME
IS JOANNA AND I AM A MAN SCHOOL
TEACHER AND I OPPOSE. EIGHTY TO
ONE. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
FOUR NINETY EIGHT AND- YEAH
YOU'RE RIGHT YEAH. YES MY NAME
IS O'NEILL I'VE ALREADY NURSE
HI OPPOSE SB. TWO TWO ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FELLER
THANKS MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE THREE SEVEN ONE YOUR LIFE
IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. THREE
SEVEN ONE. YES DAVID FISHER
RIGHT FOLLOWER FROM CATS VALLEY
STRONG OPPOSED AB TWO TWO EIGHT
SEVENTY VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
NINE TWO EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE CALL. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GIVE ME
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLEASE. YES MY NAME IS PATRICIA
LEE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO ONE EIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MONNING IT DOWN AT THE END I AM
A REGISTERED NURSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY. ONE
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT. I
THREE HOW AND EIGHT SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SEVEN THREE EIGHT
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS JOAN GRILLING KEPT TOE AND
SANDIA CRISIS FOLLOW I BILL.
TWO TWO EIGHT. ERIC IS FRAME MY-
NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY BE A NEED. TO GO AHEAD
MY THREE FORTY TWO. HELLO THEY
DON'T YES YOUR HONOR PLEASE
AHEAD THANK I. AND I OPPOSE IT
IF YOU EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE AND FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS LAUER BY
OPPOSING ANY BUILD STERILE IS
TO. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FIVE NINE AND
FOUR YOUR LINE IS A- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CHRISTINE YEAH.
OKAY ARE YOU I GREW. THAT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE THREE
AND YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE GO.
MY NAME IS DAVID KOPEL FROM
MASTER PLAN SO AND ICE OPPOSE
THIS SIGNED TO BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MODY SEAL IS AND I A THE BILL
FUNDS. H. NEXT WITNESS. TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT YOUR I ENDED
UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS PERCENT BUT A THE CONCERN
CITIZEN AND VOEPEL NAY OPPOSE
BILL THANK YOU YOU EXPERTNESS.
ONE MOMENT IT'S- MY TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RENDON LET
FACT. IN ACCORDANCE. BY STATE
OPPOSE THEIR LIGHTING CHILDREN
USE MUCH NEXT. NINE TWO EIGHTY
ONE TWO AND EIGHTY ONE YEAR IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH WELL
I DON'T. RIGHT NINE EIGHTY
THINK THE HAVE ANY BILL THAT
THANK RAMOS NO WITNESS. NINE
THREE AND THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES NAME I
HOPE THAT THAT MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPY. I GET MY.
CLINICAL OFFICE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THREE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THEY NINE
TWO NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR. NINE TWO SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SHOULD. IT
OUT. GOD CREATED MALE AND
FEMALE THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
NO AMOUNT OF. FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS AGAIN
REMINDER THAT AIM ORGANIZATION
POSITION. HELLO MY NAME IS.
INTERDEPENDENT ASSEMBLY OPPOSE
EIGHT EIGHT. EIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. I SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MAY BE ON THE LINE TO SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SEVEN ZERO.
HELLO HIGH MAINTENANCE. WEARING
YOU KNOW FROM A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB. TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
PROBABLY NO IT IS AN AND I PUT
THAT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE THIRTY ONE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M A
ROLL A CONCERNED GRANDMOTHER.
OKAY AB. TWO TWO ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
ZERO BECAUSE A LOT OF PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
THREE SEVENTY THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN. ONE MOMENT. TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE EXTEND THEM
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS LYNN MACK I AM
VERY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT THAT OF THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BY TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN BUT-
HELLO MY NAME IS. I AM A
COLLEGE GRADUATE STUDENTS
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GET YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI MY NAME IS DAN BRANDON
JONES I'M A REGISTERED NURSE
AND PARENTS DON'T STRONGLY
BECAUSE WITH THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH ANY HARRINGTON CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION
TO TAXPAYER FUNDING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FRESHMAN. NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK IN THE
NAME OF THE PERSON UNDER
MCCARTY AND WALDRON CLOSE TO
CHICAGO. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KELLY
THINK HAS SKI AND I'M HERE WITH
MY HUSBAND JOSEPH AND COFFEE.
AND WE STRONGLY OF EIGHTY TWO
ONE EIGHT ARE HISTORY. NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FIVE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS DOCTOR CHRISTINE
PEOPLE- AND I STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND FOR
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MALLORY WELL
AN ELEMENTARY THERE ARE ALL
MOTHER NATURE AND THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FOUR SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS BARBARA
MONTANA CONCERNED CITIZEN ABOUT
SINCE I CALIFORNIA PRICE
FOLLOWER AND I AM VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSED. TO AB TWENTY TWO ONE
EIGHT THIRTY NEXT WITNESS.
BUT
NINETEEN HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S J. I AM
LUCKY TO TWELVE PRIVATE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AND I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SIX WITNESS. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE HUNDRED FORTY SIX YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MARIA TAYLOR I STRONG
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU THANKS WITH THIS.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FOR FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
ONLY BE OUT ANOTHER. ONLY OPEN
AB. I THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE PROGRAM CONCERNS
SO SOME FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
DAVID SLAWSON- DOCTOR DAVIS
LOSS OF MY WIFE IS PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER SPECIAL ED IN
THE POST EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT THANK YOU EXPERTNESS.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY TO EIGHTEEN YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SORRY WE WEREN'T ABLE TO HEAR
YOUR RESPONSE. HELLO MY NAME IS
DAVID OTHER THAN A STRONGER
FEATHER AB RIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE TWO SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CLAUDIA ORTIZ
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU. THANKS
WITNESS. NINE THREE THIRTY SIX-
CINDY THOMAS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY I'M CINDY THOMAS I'M A
CONCERNED PARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NINE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN OR THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JEFF WATER. AND I
ONLY BE MONDAY THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MIND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BROUGHT I'VE
BEEN VERY VERY I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED DOCTOR OF NATURAL
MEDICINE. I STRONGLY OPPOSE TAX
DOLLARS BEING USED VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ELSA
CHAU I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THREE
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
THREE. YES MY NAME. MY NAME IS
ANTHONY AMENDED OPPOSED AB.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWO NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANNA KEEN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE NINE THREE SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH YES MY NAME IS JOHN
STRAIGHTER AND I AM ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THAT WOULD
CHANGE IS VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MICHAEL THE SPIRITS OF THE
AMERICAN FAMILY THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTING TO BREAK YOUR
CLINIC AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MY
NAME IS LIFE THAT ROAM ALL OF
THE TAXPAYER AYE OPPOSED THE
STERILIZATION OF SHELVES THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS ST. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MANY MAJORITY MORENO
MYSTERON WE OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
EIGHT ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CARL GAVE
CHAVEZ. PASTORING CONCERNED
PARENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
X. WITNESS. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DAVE LARA AND I OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHT. THANK YOU X.
WITNESS. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATHY A CHOCOLATE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS A TAX YEAH
I AM AB ONE EIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MY FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY
NAME IS TRACY CARPENTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANKS WITH. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JUNE SHELDON.
RETIRED UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU
CONNECTS WITNESS. MY THREE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND REYES JOBS
OUT AND PULLED THE BILL THAT
FUNDS THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWO SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT HANDER DIDN'T HAVE
ANY THREE OF US. LIVING UNTIL
NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE AT NINE FIVE TWENTY THREE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIVE TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
BALDING I DON'T. ASSEMBLY DINO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINETY THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS A LIFELINE CREDIT OPEN
CHICAGO CALIFORNIA BUT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS. NINE ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARTINEZ FROM
CAN I CALIFORNIA I'M AGAINST
AIRLIFTING CHILDREN AND ADULTS
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LARRY UNDERGO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL TWENTY.
EXPERTNESS. NINE FIVE FOURTEEN
OR FIVE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JENNIFER AND I AM IN
SCHOOL TEACHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
OR THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY
THREE THIRTY THREE THREE
HUNDRED AND EUROPEN. THE OTHER
MONEY TODAY HI I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE BECAUSE- I.
ONE OF THIS BILL JENNINGS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK GOODNESS.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE'RE. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT OR
THREE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH ARE YOU LIVING ON.
TWO FIVE THIRTY THREE THIRTY
NINE FIVE THIRTY THREE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO.
DOWNSHIFT HELLO MY NAME IS
ANGELA KALINDA GO RETIRED
TEACHER AND I LOOKED AT. TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FOUR FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GERRY OKAY
SICK AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
EXPERTNESS. NINE ONE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YES MY NAME
IS HELLO JOHN HELLO AND FINING
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS AND I FIRMLY
OPPOSE. AB ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT OR FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACQUELYN YEAH I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO POINT EIGHT
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH SIX
WITNESS. NINE FIVE THIRTY ONE
OR FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
YOU'RE INVITED OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BELIEVING CALLING FROM
SHOULDER TO CALIFORNIA. MY
FAMILY AND I WE OPPOSED TO TWO
ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CHERYL PETRUZELLI A CONCERNED
GRANDMOTHER I ALSO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN ARCUEIL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS. REALLY LOOK AT THAT AND
THEN LA LET ASSEMBLY. I'M NOT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE HE IF YOU
LIKE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS THE NETWORK SHOWS
I'M A PARENT AND A GRANDPARENT
AND STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME BACKGROUND
NAKASHIMA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
FOR. RIGHT YEAH. HI. AND I'M
ACTUALLY CALLING IN THREE
WORKERS AS OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU WE'RE CURRENTLY TAKING
OPPOSITION BUT THANK YOU FOR
CALLING SUPPRESSING YOUR
SUPPORT. X. WITNESS. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS LINDA O'BRIEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOHN CHIANG CARL
FRAMPTON DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND
I'M OPPOSED. BILL AB. RIGHT
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MARGARITA GALICIAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT THANK YOU THANKS FOR THIS.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAMBERLEY CHINO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ABQ MONEY THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM NOT EVEN DOLLARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE BUT-
SHE MY NAME IS JENNY THERE. I'M
A TEACHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MIND THREE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
AMBER OR TEETH A REGISTERED
NURSE I OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS KIM MITCHELL
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
TINA HAIL FROM RAMONA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE NINE ONE FIFTY NINE. ONE
ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
FIFTY NINE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEGATIVE NINE FIVE
SIXTEEN FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
SIXTEEN YOU MAY BE ON NEARLY GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON. TO LINE. THREE
EIGHTY FOUR NINE THREE EIGHTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PEOPLE
HAD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JILL RUSSELL AND ELEMENTARY
EXTENDICARE TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU OUR MODERATOR CAN YOU GIVE
ME A AT LEAST HEARD. AT LEAST
HALF AN HOUR OF A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF WITH
HER. A SLIGHTLY LESS TIME BUT-
SIMILE AND SUPPORT CAN YOU TELL
ME HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE ARE ON
THE LINE AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR. WE HAVE
FIFTY SEVEN HOW MANY FIFTY R.
FIFTEEN FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO FIFTY YES. OKAY. GEN
BECAUSE OF TIME CONSTRAINTS- I
WILL TOO LET'S LET'S GO AHEAD
AND WILL TAKE FIFTEEN MORE
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY- ACTUALLY
WILL TAKE IT BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO WERE
HOPING TO ALSO SPEAK IN FAVOR
WHO WERE HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
ON THE LINE SO LET'S GO AHEAD
AND JUST OPEN UP FOR PEOPLE TO
EXPRESS AGAIN YOUR POSITION FOR
AGAINST ITS NAME IF YOU HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION OR IS. NOW OKAY
I'LL GIVE YOU A QUICK FIVE.
OKAY SO I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE A
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION SO WHILE
WE GO AHEAD AND TAKE ANOTHER.
TEN MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION
AGAIN IF PEOPLE CAN LISTEN ON
THE LINE WE CAN TRY TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE THERE'S
A LITTLE TIME LAG ON THERE
AGAIN IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION PEOPLE BEEN VERY GOOD
ABOUT THIS AND LET'S JUST SEE
IF WE CAN TRY TO GET THROUGH TO
EVERYBODY IN THE NEXT TEN
MINUTES. THANK YOU. SO AGAIN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MODERATE
RIGHT. YOU'RE WELCOME ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT FOR SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
PLEASE LEAVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLEASE.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PLAN FOR
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR-
YES MY NAME. I'M UP HM HM
OPPOSITE. EIGHT ONE EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THIS NINE ONE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN I'M
SORRY NINE ONE OH SEVEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IN LINE ONE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD OF THIS BUT THE DOCTOR
JAMES SANTIAGO GRISLY A
MINERALOGIST PRACTICING IN THE
HEART OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN
SAN DIEGO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF MEDICAL
ETHICS TO BEST PROTECT ARTICLE
JUST TAKING NAME ALWAYS THESE
POSITIONS OF YOUR POSITIONS. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. OKAY. ONE MOMENT I
WOULD REOPEN THE LINE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOU'VE INTRODUCED THIS
YEAR I HAD A QUESTION FOR AND
AGAINST AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN.
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN WHERE YOU
FOR OR AGAINST. YEAH WE OPPOSED
TO IT- AS WRITTEN THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NEXT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU. OKAY. NINETEEN ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES MY NAME IS
THE FINER FROM SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY I'M RETIRED A PROUD
PARENT OF TWO BIOLOGICAL FEMALE
PLEASE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH%
THE DOCTORS OPPOSITION OF- IN
THE. TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANKS
FOR MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FIVE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JAMES LANE. AND I'M A
RETIRED PHARMACIST. AND IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU THANKS FOR
THIS. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE. YOUR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. RIGHT FOR FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS DICK
RUSSELL I'M TRYING PASTOR AND
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FIVE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GALLAGHER SAID AND WHY
KRISTIN MAKERS AND THOUGH BOTH
REGISTERED NURSES BOTH OPPOSE
EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU. EXPERTNESS. ONE ONE NINETY
EIGHT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE
CONCERNED. AND I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE NINE ONE SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES GAIL LEVIN ON.
BEHALF OF THE JUDEO CHRISTIAN
CAUCUSES PUBLIC CANCEL EARLY
PHOTOS. EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHT
THING THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THREE SEVENTEEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN'T PHILOSOPHIA FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY I AM OPPOSED
TO AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX WITNESS. ONE MOMENT.
NINE FIVE TWENTY TWO NINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TWENTY. YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LARA CAMBIADO AND
MAY HAVE THANK YOU. AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. FIVE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS GREGORY
THAT. ME AND MY WIFE. K.
OPPOSED THE BILL THAT THANKS
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE THIRTEEN. ONE MOMENT MY ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO
AHEAD MY NAME SOMEBODY GOT IT
ON MY TAXPAYERS AND MONITORING
THAT COULD VALLEY BUT WE
STANDING ALLIANCE THAT CHILDREN
AND TEN THOUSANDTH OF PARENTING
THANK YOU CERTAINLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE ZERO FIVE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FIVE ZERO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CINDY OJEDA. AND I AM.
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWENTY FIVE
ZERO FIVE. HELLO I AM MY NAME
IS DANIEL HEDA I'M REGISTERED
NURSING CONCERNED PARENTS. AND
I OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THAT IS
MY NUMBER ONE THREE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. ONE THREE
NINE BILLION. YEAH. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CHáVEZ FROM ONLINE
PROTECT CHILDREN AND COMMITTEE
MEETING ALTHOUGH THEY MADE BAD
I'M STRONGLY AGAINST- AND I
THINK IT'S AN ADULT NO I MAYBE
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HE ONE MOMENT PLEASE
AND THAT IS. ONE TWO ONE SIX
NINE TWO ONE SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME IS
MELISSA WALTON REGISTERED
SPENDING WHICH INTERPRETER HOME
EDUCATOR AND CONCERNED PARENT.
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
THANKS WITNESS. HE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THAT IS MY NUMBER FIVE
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FIVE EIGHT SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS LEANDRO I AM A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
CONCERNED PARENT AND HOME
INDICATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT THAT IS LINE. SIX TWO
SIX ONE SIX TWO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE O'NEILL AND I
REPRESENT ALLIANCE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY OF PROTECTING
CHILDREN THANK YOU SORRY
THIRTEEN THANK YOU AND I THANK
YOU. HIS ONE EIGHT YOU LEFT
PEOPLE THANK THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. CAN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. NINE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JIM THE LITTLE OF CONCERNED
PARENTS FROM L. A. COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT WOULD BE
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANKS
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FIVE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY THREE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KATHERINE DRIVER FROM LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO
TELL YOU I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSING. AB ONE TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR IT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE FOUR
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DOCTOR
CHRISTINA JOHNSON CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST I'M VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL TAKE
ONE MORE CALL. THAT ARE MAKING
AN- OKAY AND THEN NINE FIVE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY NINE
FIVE THIRTY TO AT. NINE FIVE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEFF AND I'M CALLING FROM UP
IN THE CALIFORNIA. I AM A
TAXPAYER AND A VETERAN AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK THANK
YOU SAID THERE WELL THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT AS WE WERE TAKING
OPPOSITION BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONYSO WE'RE- WE
HAVE. HEARD OVER FORTY MINUTES
OF PUBLIC COMMENT. IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE IN. HOW MANY PEOPLE
AWAITING A THE LINE AND WHILE
FIGURE THAT OUT I JUST WANNA
SAY IS THAT. YOU ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE WITH.
AND TO MAKE COMMENTS AS WELL
AND TO EXPRESS YOUR POSITION ON
THIS. BILL SO- MODERATELY TELL
ME HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE ARE ON
THE LINE. WE HAVE FORTY THREE
STILL ON THE LINE FOR.
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT WELL GIVEN
TIME CONSTRAINTS- I'VE JUST
URGE WE RECOGNIZE THE FORTY
THREE PEOPLE STILL ON THE LINE
AS WE'RE TAKING OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY OF AN OPPORTUNITY
ALSO. SPECIFICALLY MAKE
COMMENTS ON OUR WEB PAGE- SO
WE'RE GOING TO. MOVE ON I WOULD
NOTE THAT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE
PHONE LINES I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE WERE ALSO SOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE AND SUPPORT TO AND FORTY
WERE UNABLE TO GET ON. I WILL
FORWARD THEM ALSO- UP TO TEN
MINUTES IF THERE'S ANY PEOPLE
WANNA TESTIFY FOR- YOU CAN GET
ON THE LINE NOW AND- WE WILL
TAKE UP TO TEN MINUTES IN WHICH
CASE WE WILL THEN BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE AND THEN YOU TWO
CAN ALSO MAKE COMMENTS ONLINE
IF NECESSARY. AS WELL SO HELD
FOR ONE MORE UP TO YOU FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN FAVOR WHO ARE
UNABLE TO GET ON THE LINE AT UP
TO TEN MINUTES. AND THEN WE
WILL BE MOVING TO COMMITTEE- SO
AGAIN THANK YOU AND APOLOGIZE
FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO GET TO- BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME TIME CONSTRAINTS AND
WE DO NEED TO. LATER BUSINESS
AT HERE. ALL RIGHT- MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWENTY TWO ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE OF
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
POINT SIX SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES THAT- MAYBE DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW AND I STAND WITH GOD AYE
OPPOSED. THE BILL THANKS VERY
MUCH WE'RE NOW AKING ANY
TESTIMONY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT- AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU. MY EIGHT SIX FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO AFTER A YEAR
AND I AM A AFTER THAT BUT IT
CAN UNITY AND I THOUGHT LIKE
THAT PART AB. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEFF AND I'M CALLING FROM
ALPENA CALIFORNIA. I AM A%
TAXPAYER AND A VETERAN AND I'M
CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THE
TRANSLATOR WELL THAT'S EXACTLY
FONG THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT A
WITNESS. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MEGAN THIS
BILL. OKAY THANK YOU HAS NOT
GONE ON TWICE IN YOUR PREJUDICE
AGAINST THAT THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME. I'M FROM
EVERYTHING CALIFORNIA I NEED
CAN USE AND UTILITY MUTILATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE ARE
TAKING ANY FINAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN AGAIN IT'S NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE. BUT. HE MAD EDUCATION IT.
YEAH I HAVE IT YEAH ME. YES WE
DO I DO NOT GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIS IS TRACY
SCHMIDT I'M FROM SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL. THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH WE'RE TAKING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- WE HAVE
HEARD TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. NEXT WITNESS ONE
SIX SEVEN THANK YOU NINE SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS VANESSA RIVERA FROM.
MANY OF MY WIFE AND I ARE
INVOLUNTARY WITH TRANSLATE YOU
KNOW COLLISION IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MERRY PAJERO AND I CALLED THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT HAPPENED
A LOT IT. BEAR WITH. YOU CAN BE.
I'M SORRY WE COULD NOT HEAR YOU
WHETHER YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE MOTION. MY NAME IS OFFERED
AT HEART. AB OKAY THANK YOU
WHAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
ARE DEADLINE SUPPORT TESTIMONY
AT THIS POINT IN. TIME WE HAVE
HEARD FROM OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINES TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVEN'T EVEN
REGINALD IS MY STRUGGLE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT.
THIS TIME FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M SORRY I
MUST HAVE GOTTEN PUT ON HERE I
WAS ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION FROM
BEFORE I WAS ON HOLD FOR TWO
HOURS SO. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
EVERYBODY ON THE COMMITTEE
SORRY FOR THE LONG EVENING
DOUGLAS. DAHLE THANK YOU. GET
ANY AN IDEA I'VE SIXTEEN. OH
I'M SORRY WE DO HAVE FOUR
COLORS ALL RIGHT. AND MINE FIVE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE HEAR YOU
PLEASE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION PLEASE. RUBIO ORANGE
COUNTY BECAUSE THEY WITNESS AYE
OPPOSED AB THANK YOU SANDRA TO
EIGHTEEN OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE
TAKING SUPPORT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. NINE ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY LET ME YES IT. IS
OKAY HI MY NAME MJ BROWN I'M
THE BOARD OF TO GET LA A LOT OF
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU ARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. NINE SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTYYOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE MAY BE ON
MUTE NINE SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY OR SIX THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO NINE
SEVEN FIFTY THREE NINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE CHECK OUT MY LOOK AT.
BUT YOU'RE ON MY NAME IS LAURIE
CONRAD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE A. B. OKAY I MEASURE FOR
CAROLINE SHE WAS VERY MUCH- WE
ARE TAKING SUPPORT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WE'VE HEARD FROM
OPPOSITION. DURATION FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIX YOUR. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS RAY DONOVAN AND I'M
A PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND
I'M ALSO A FORMER SOCIAL WORKER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION AND THAT AB TWENTY
TWO. THANK I HAVE HEARD FROM A-
ANY OTHER CALLERS AND SUPPORT.
AT THIS TIME. NINE SEVEN SEVEN
DAYS BY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SO OR SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TJ
MILLER I AM A RESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY AND I'M
CALLING IT STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER ONE MARK OKAY ONE MORE
THANK YOU. ONE MORNING GIVE IT
JUST A MOMENT WHEN WE GOT TO
THE LINE NUMBER. NINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY LET'S CHECK IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY SCIENTISTS HAVE PASSED
MEDICAL RESEARCHER. CAPITAL
MOBILE CHANGE FIVE REJECTING
THIS EXAM TYPICAL THANKS VERY
MUCH WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT AND
AT THE LAST CALLER. YEAH WE DO
HAVE ONE NINE NINE NINE FORTY
AND THIS IS JUST. THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO OR FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
HELLO IS IT ME YES IT IS. HELLO
MATE I THANK YOU WITH THE
FOUNDATION IN ONTO COUNTY WE
HAVE THOUSAND. WITH THE ONLINE
TWO HOUR THREE HOUR LOOK AT
CHEN HELLO. USE OUR MONEY TO.
OKAY THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS I KNOW THAT MANY
PEOPLE BEEN WAITING ON THE
PHONE WE'VE HEARD. IT'S GONNA
BE MATH TEST ME OVER AN HOUR BY
HOUR A HALF OF TESTIMONY AND
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ON THIS
ISSUE- ENCOURAGE YOU THAT IF
YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO. MAKE IT ON
THE PHONES YOU CAN STILL. SEND
US YOUR POSITION IN YOUR
COMMENTS TO OUR WEBSITE. AND
CONTINUE TO COMMENT ON THIS.
PARTICULAR BILL AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. I AM NOW GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. AND ASK IF ANY OF
THE MEMBERS HERE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
GONZALEZ. YES THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR AND I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ITEM IN WHICH- I AM
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN SUPPORT-
HAVING A DISTRICT WHERE. HAVE A
VERY LONG LDP COMMUNITY BUT
PARTICULARLY WHERE WE KNOW THAT
THE TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY NEEDS
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- NOT ONLY
JUST WITH DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
ACCESS BUT WITH ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THAT LIMIT THEIR
PROGRESSWE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS- A SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR
THEM THROUGH THIS HEALTH AND
WELLNESS IN EQUITY FUND- IN
ADDITION I HOPE THAT WE CAN
ALSO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSIONS
FOR TRANSGENDER YOUTH THE
CHALLENGES OF CO THAT ARE
UNIQUE FOR THEM AND THEY ALSO
TO NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR WILL BE
CERTAINLY DOING THAT SO I WANT
TO JUST THANK HIM AGAIN. AND
THE SUPPORTERS FOR- COMING
ONLINE DISCUSSING THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT ITEM
AND I WOULD LOVE TO CO AUTHOR
THIS IS WELL IF I'M ABLE TO
THANK YOU AND ALL MOTION WHEN
APPROPRIATE AS WELL OKAY SO-
BEING MOVED BY SERRA GONZALEZ-
SO RUBIO. YES THANK YOU WELL IN
THE END OF TIME I JUST GONNA
ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PALM BEACH JUST DID IT BUT I
WANT TO BE AS I GOT. HUNDRED
AND HUNDREDS. NOT SUPPORT SOME
THAT'S THEIR LIFE IS. SET THOSE
ARE PAUL I DECIDED TO INCREASE
THE BILL VERY CAREFULLY AND I
DIDN'T FIND ANYTHING ABOUT
STERILIZING CHILDREN BUT WHAT
IT DID SAY VERY CLEARLY THAT IT
WILL PROVIDE GRANTS TO
TRANSLATE ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE MORE INCLUSIVE SERVICE
AND THAT MEANS EVERYTHING FROM
HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES
TO ASSIST. AND A LOT AND SO I
WAS VERY EAGER TO READ THE BILL
AND HAS. ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
THAT SAYS WE'RE STERILIZING
CHILDREN SO WITH THAT I ALSO
FOUGHT PASSED TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. OKAY CENTER TADO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW AT. I
RECEIVED MANY MANY CALLS- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FROM MY
DISTRICT- BUT- YOU KNOW I
STRONGLY FEEL THAT THERE'S AND
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE BEING
MISLED EXACTLY ABOUT WHAT THIS
BILL MEANS AND WHAT IT IS. AND
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE FOR BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A RIGHT THING TO
DO SO FOR THAT REASON I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD. TEAM LEYVA IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANYONE ELSE ON
THIS FLOOR WE RECEIVED HUNDREDS
OF CALLS. ABOUT TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL. AND I JUST FEEL BAD
FOR THE- WHO WERE CAUGHT TO. US
TO VOTE NO BECAUSE I DO THINK
THEY WERE MISLED. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT TALKS
ABOUT STERILIZING CHILDREN. IT
REALLY TALKS ABOUT HEALTH. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFY AS
TRANS GENDER. NON CONFORMING OR
INTERSEX AND I JUST FILL UP THE
FOLKS THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION
MAYBE DIDN'THAVE. THE FACTS.
OR MAYBE THEY DID AND THEY JUST
WERE CALLING TO TRY AND GET US
TO VOTE NO BUT I'M HAVE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. AGAIN
THANK AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR ANY
OTHERQUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS YES CENTER
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR IF I MAY YES. SO IT
THE BILL LET'S SEE HERE ALLOWS
FOR MEDICAL THE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS AND FUNDING- THAT
PROVIDE GENDER CONFORMING
HEALTH CARE SERVICES CAN YOU
TELL US. CAN YOU GIVE US A LIST
OF WHAT GENDER CONFORMING
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ARE. SOME
NUMBER. OF GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
THAT COULD BE IT COULD BE
ADVISED ON HORMONES AND
THEREFORE HE WOULD NEED SPECIAL
TRAINING. ARE FOR THATAND THIS
IS WHAT THIS BILL INTENDS TO DO.
IT WOULD PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
THEM THAT. COULD WELL BE THE
WAY THE BILL IS WRITTEN IN
THERE WOULD BE NONPROFIT TO
HAVE TO APPLY FOR THE DOLLARS
ARE WHO COULD WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH CLINICS AND
OR HOSPITALS. OR AMONGST
THEMSELVES. SORRY TO THE CHAIR-
OKAY SO- ONE EXAMPLE WOULD BE
THE FUNDING COULD GO TOWARDS
TRAINING HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS ON. HORMONE
THERAPY DINER STANEK CORRECTLY.
IF YOU WISH TO ANSWER SOME
NUMBER OF LIQUOR HYPOTHETICALLY
YES. OKAY SO I JUST.BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEEN COMMENTS
SUGGESTING THAT IT IT THE BILL
WOULD NOT ALLOW FOR THAT BUT IT
SOUNDS AS THOUGH IT WOULD- NOT
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE ONLY
THING THAT THE FUNDING TO GO
TOWARD BUT THAT IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT OCCURRED. THAT
COULD GO TOWARD SAID THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING. SINCE OUR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. A
SENTIMENTAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF THE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND I. RECEIVE AT LEAST
ONE POSITIVE ELEMENT OF OUR
CURRENT WAY OF DOING BUSINESS
AS A RESULT OF CALL OF IT IS
THE OPPORTUNITY PEOPLE HAVE TO
CALL IN VERSUS YOU KNOW COME IN
IT COMING IN. TO THE ACTUAL
CAPITAL YOU KNOW ONE THING LIKE
MEANING YOU ARE GOT HUNDREDS OF
CALLS BUT WE ACTUALLY DID THE
ANALYSIS. VERY FEW OF THE MORE
FROM MY ACTUAL DISTRICT AND SO
ITHINK IT'S IN ALL HONESTY
WILL WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
OPINION YOU REACH OUT TO YOUR
ALL ELECTED OFFICIALS AFTER YOU
SHOULD CALL YOUR ELECTED
OFFICIAL. WE GOT EIGHT HUNDRED
CALLS IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE
FIFTY OTHER MORE ACTUAL
CONSTITUENTS- I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OKAY ST NINE- SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU A SUMMER SANTIAGO FOR
BRING THIS BILL FORD I. THINK
JUSTICE- MANY OF. MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE NOTED THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A TRANSGENDER
WELLNESS IN EQUITY FUND. A FUND
ACTUALLY UNFORTUNATELY- DATA
HAS NOT BEEN FUND IN OUR BUDGET
YET SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIND
SOME FUNDS IN THEIR- I WOULD
MAKE A NOTE THAT- IS A
PEDIATRICIAN MY OWN. SPECIAL
SOCIETY THE AMERICAN CAVEAT
TRIPS- CALIFORNIA HAS EXPRESSED
SUPPORT. FOR THIS BILL AND I
WOULD EXPECT THAT THE BILL
HOPEFULLY WOULD FIND. TRAININGS
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO PRACTICE THE
STANDARD OF CARE. SANDERS CARE
DOESN'T ESTABLISHED BY A BEFORE
COLLEGE WILL AN EXPERT IN THE
FIELD- THAT'S WHAT AMERICA
CAN'T PEDIATRICS DOES AND I'M
SURE OTHER SPECIALTY SOCIETIES
AS WELL. BECAUSE AFTER ALL I
MEAN WE WANT TO PROVIDE FUNDS
TO SUPPORT HEALTH CARE WE
WANTED FOR RIDE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE BASED ON OUR BEST
SCIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE. AND WITH
THAT. I WANT TO I. THANK YOU
FOR READING THIS BILL FOR ASK
SOMEONE THANK OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE TESTIFIED
INCLUDING- TO MY CONSTITUENCY
WITHIN THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKE AND
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL AND I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. BEING
HERE FOR MAKING THAT TESTIMONY
ON. APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING TO CUT
ONE OF THE MONSTER I DO HAVE TO
DISAPPEAR AFTER MEETING TIME
WITH THAT SO THAT'S THAT'S PART
OF MY JOB HERE. BUT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE WONDERFUL WORK
THE GENDER HEALTH CENTER DOES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND
APPRECIATE THEIR TESTIMONY HERE
WHAT THAT. SOME NUMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE- THE
COMMITTEES ROBUST DEBATE- AND
ITS GENEROSITY WITH TIME IN
THE- THE- OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE. THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
DURING COLD IT- UNFORTUNATELY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN- MISLED ABOUT
THIS BILL WILL BE VERY CLEAR
AND SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL. NOTHING I
WILL REPEAT. TALK ABOUT
STERILIZING KIDS. NOTHING I
WILL REPEAT IN THIS BILL.
POINTS TO ANYTHING TO DO WITH
CHILDREN. SALAI IN APPRECIATE
THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT THAT SOME
HAVE HAVE ENGAGED IN- I THINK
THE DIMMEST LIGHT AND IT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE. I THINK IT'S
FEARMONGERING IN GOOD FOR SOUND
BITES. BUT QUITE FRANKLY
THEY'VE COME OUT OF GROUPS A IN
FACT BOTH OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ONE I BELIEVE WAS FROM OKLAHOMA
AND THE OTHER FROM GEORGIA NOT
TAKE AWAY FROM WHAT THEY
BELIEVE ARE BUT IT'S BEEN
UNFORTUNATE THAT IS BEEN FEAR
MONGER IN USE FOR SOUND BITES
THE BILL VERY CLEAR. EVERYBODY
DOES IT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
TRANS GENDER WELLNESS AND
EQUITY FUND. I HOP ON A- IN
THIS. TO JUST GRANT TO THE
TRITONS GENDER LEVEL- OF
NONPROFITS AND ORGANIZATIONS
AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES. FOR TJ
PEOPLE. NOTHING LIKE WHAT'S
BEEN SAID IN A VERY SIMPLE IT
WOULD PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
PRACTICES. TO NURSES AND
DOCTORS. OUR ON TGI E. T.
FRIDAY MASK CLIMATE. ISSUES ARE
AND HOW TO BEST SERVE. BUT I
WANT TO REPEAT THIS ONE MORE
TIME IF IT IS VERY IMPORTANT IN
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED IT
HERE NOTHING. IN THIS BILL.
FIGMA SIGNIFIED ANY SORT OF
ACTION TO ANY KID. OR
STERILIZATION THE KIDS AND I
THINK THIRTY COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WOULD REFLECTED THAT IF IT HAD
BEEN THE TAKES AND IT'S NOT THE
CASE. BUT NOT REFLECTED IN THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS. THE GAUGE
MET UNFORTUNATELY- THEY'VE BEEN
MISLED. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO THE BILL'S AB TWENTY
TWO ONE EIGHT IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ THE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I GONZALEZHI AND
SALAS I GROW FURTADO I DON'T I
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. MITCHELL
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
MONNING AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SEVEN ONE. THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FINALLY WE HAVE
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT- ITEM
NUMBER SIX. FROM AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE A SEMI RECORDS SILVA
THAT WOULD BE A- I THINK
THAT'S- TWO PROBES AS AMENDED
CORRECT AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY THREE BY SUMMER MAYES
AGAIN- FOR TO APPROPRIATIONS AS
AMENDED- SO ARE THERE ANY.
THEIR MOTION FOR THE CONTENT
OWNER OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER MINING SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CAN I CAN I SALAS HI
SALAS I. HER TADO I'M TITLE I
LEYVA BY. MELENDEZ I. AND AS I
MITCHELL. HI MITCHELL I'M HI
MONEY IN RUBIO. RUBIO AYE AND
LEYVA AYE. EIGHT OKAY THE
CONSENT DOLLARS EIGHT ZERO
RIGHT WITH THAT FIRST OF I HOPE
YOU BIG MEET INTELLIGENCE I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY HERE
TO- THIS IS PROBABLY OUR LAST
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARINGS
POSSIBLE MIGHT HAVE ONE OFF THE
FLOOR BUT- WE'LL SEE BUT I JUST
WANTED AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR DEDICATION ONE THANKS THE
A TEAM HERE. THE STAFF IS
WORKING VERY HARD AND I KNOW
THIS IS BEEN CHALLENGE YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING- TO GET A
HEARINGS GOING DOING THIS
REMOTE HEARING THE MODERATORS
THAT THE MANAGE ALL THE
DIFFERENT CALLS. WE WANT TO
THANK I WANTED. ALSO HEALTH
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKED VERY
HARD TO HELP YOU SEEN OF SOME
THE PRODUCTS OF THE WORK OF
COURSE- ACHIEVEMENTS ALL
MELANIE MARINO BUT ALSO A
CONSULTANCY TERRY BOWDEN.
KIMBERLY CHANDRIS DEUS VINCENT
MARCHAND AND ARE COMMITTEES. IN
ON POSH COURTNEY SKINNER THEIR
HARD WORK. TO MAKE THESE THINGS
HAPPEN. THANK YOU. AND THEN
FINALLY I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE ALL OF YOU BUT WE
HAVE TO I THINK TO MEMBERS- ONE
OF WHICH IS TERMING OUT CENTER
MINING THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
ALONG STATE COMMITTEE MEMBER
AND- CENTER MITCHELL AT.
BECAUSE I WANT TO WISH YOU ALL
THE BEST THIS COULD BE YOUR
LAST HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING-
I HOPE YOU WISH YOU EVERY
SUCCESS AND- DEFINITELY DON'T
WANT TO STOP DO YOU THINK
YOU'LL RECOGNIZE YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL. SO WITH THAT AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE- ALSO JUST ON
BRIEFLY RECOGNIZE ALSO CENTER
NIELSEN WHO DID SERVE AS VICE
CHAIR WHO ALTHOUGH STILL
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW FOR HIS.
WONDERFUL CONTRIBUTIONS
COMMITTEE SO AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK. I WOULD
WE CAN. THIS OF THIS HEARING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND WE ARE. THANK YOU. OKAY.